with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
the
rumors
started in the morning
some guys in afghanistan got hit
there's some wounded guys
and
[Music]
you don't know who it is at first you
don't know what team
east coast west coast
you're just wondering
pretty soon we we know it's west coast
guys
and
you know the transition is happening so
you got two teams over there at the time
team one and team seven
and now you know you got wounded guys
and then you're thinking of
who who do i know
and and at this point
i kind of know everybody
because i've been putting all these
platoons through training for the last
couple years so i know i'm gonna
recognize names
when they come through
and then you're waiting
and then and then we hear it's one guy
it's only one guy and that's
that's good you know good it's only one
guy how bad is he
and it doesn't sound good
and you you're hearing
reports is a massive ied
how bad
real bad how bad is real bad
real bad
and then you start to
ask
that horrible question to yourself is he
gonna make it
and
then you start getting reports back they
don't know if he's gonna make it and
that's not a good sign because team guys
are usually positive thinkers
who
we think we can survive anything
so when you hear a team guy say
he doesn't know if someone's going to
make it it doesn't usually bode well
and there's a
weird
strange
silence around everyone's kind of
waiting to hear
and
quite frankly everyone's waiting to hear
a name
and waiting to hear the outcome
and wondering if we're going to lose a
brother
finally i get an actual call
an actual call the distant voice from
one of my buddies over in afghanistan
and i get the first hand report of
what's going on
and yeah confirmed massive
massive ied
i get the name
dan knawson he's
one of the platoon commanders that
i just put through work up great guy
humble
tough
locked on
and
i asked that question you know is he
gonna make it
and
the response is
you know something along the lines of he
lost both legs and he's got massive
trauma to his lower abdomen
looks like they have them stabilized the
guys did a great job and
this is like a stall tactic not
answering my question is he gonna make
it
and the answer comes again um
i don't know
and you sit with that for a while
because there's only one thing that's
going to give you the answer and that's
time
only time will tell
and in this particular case
we were blessed
because
dan connauson did make it
he survived a
massive ied
that
would have killed
probably anyone
but somehow he was able to survive
and we can talk about that because we're
lucky enough tonight to have the honor
of having dan with us
here
to share some of his experiences and his
lessons learned
from his life
and from his time
in the seal teams
dan
thanks for
thanks for coming by man thanks for
joining us thanks jaco thanks for having
me here that was uh you know one of
those
weird days at the teams where i i
remember this when when you got blown up
and
that
you know this would happen you know guys
would get wounded you'd hear those
rumors when you got to work someone saw
message traffic or someone talked to one
of their friends and it would just get
you would have so little information
and then as the time as the day goes on
you sort of
the picture becomes more and more clear
and i i really remember that
well um you know just because i was in
trade i'd already lost guys and and
[Music]
um was not looking forward to going to a
funeral
so
i'm freaking glad you're here man i'm
glad you didn't have to go to that
funeral
um
let's start at the beginning man um
let's start out where you came from and
and how you grew up and all that let's
get to it
sure i'm
born and raised in kansas fifth
generation family farm
from 1874 i grew up
roaming around outside
i had a bb gun i got in a little bit of
trouble with the bb gun shooting some
targets i shouldn't have been aiming at
but really i think
growing up
on a farm in kansas i developed a
deep-seated love of just being outside i
think this comes into play later in my
story were you uh was your family a
farming family is that what you did they
did for a living yes my it's on my
maternal side of the family my mom's
father his his so my grandfather his
grandfather
came out this is homestead act 1870s if
you farm the land you get to keep it
after a certain amount of time and they
built the limestone home a limestone
barn still stands today that's where i
was born and raised i was a kid i didn't
think anything of it just where i grew
up but now i realize how special that
was
at 240 acres and my grandfather had
three daughters one of whom was my
mother and so the farming didn't get
passed down and
i did not grow up as a farmer but i
certainly took advantage of the tractor
rides
and then what was your
was your grandparents in the military at
all
my dad's father was u.s army world war
ii and uh i don't know
he is no longer alive i don't know the
extent of action that he saw but he was
in the european theater in the later
part of the war
and what about your dad
my father served in the marine corps he
in 1965 enlisted
he
didn't get drafted he chose to enlist
and he chose to enlist in the marine
corps
and he did three tours and the third
and and my father is no longer alive as
well to talk about some of the specifics
and as a kid when i grew up he didn't
talk about the specifics but
generally speaking he gave me a glimpse
of life into the marine corps into the
military and
actually i wanted to be a marine in high
school
my
dad at the end of his third tour did one
of these small teams where you're
working with locals kind of going
village to village four-man teams
that's the last thing he did and he
exited the marine corps in 1968 and
was was done
and he didn't he didn't share much with
you about that when he was not about
combat when i was a kid i remember in
our family room we had some old
storage items and i was
combing through this this is while he
was still alive and i saw citations uh
navy combination metal bronze uh not i'm
sorry a purple heart
and uh
he he was under mortar fire at one point
and
rendered
life-saving aid to a teammate to another
marine and so he's commended for that
but yeah i i don't have specifics i also
found some old letters that he had
written home that were pretty
interesting just you know it's a glimpse
into my father when he was
23 24 years old uh riding home from what
was he saying in the letters you should
have brought him oh he could have read
them i think there was some mention of r
r and uh
i
probably don't need to go into the
specifics
i guess it depends who he was riding
home yeah yeah and what'd he do when he
got out of the marine corps in 1968
so he he ended up going uh to business
school in cornell
he did have a degree from iowa state
he's from iowa and so he had a college
degree enlisted in the marine corps 1968
gets out he would have been 25 at that
point went to cornell
and my mother enlisted in the marine
corps even though he had a college
degree yeah
do you are you tracking any uh any like
decision making process on that was he
just fired up for the marine corps or
i think it was a little bit of rebellion
against his father
and his father had said if you're going
to go in the military
do not go in the marine corps
any service not that one
[Laughter]
well yeah if his dad served in world war
ii
he might have had that impression that
hey you don't want to beat the marines
you're going to be in the you know
storming beaches over in the pacific you
want to have a more plush job like
storming the beaches in the in the
european theater i don't know
interesting so you think he wrote a
little bit of a rebellion rebellion i
think and i think he probably
wanted to be part of something special
and i think that is something i've seen
growing up on a farm in kansas i think
you have work ethic but you also want to
be part of something special you like to
be part of a team and it's a
continuation of that going in the
military
so he gets done with business school and
then how do you meet your mom and end up
in
out there in kansas on the 248th
40 acres of beauty yeah my my mother
ended up in new york city she was a
secretary and in the office there was a
woman who introduced some and i i need
to talk to my mother about the specifics
of how they got introduced but on the
first date she didn't like my father as
well as well as would indicate even the
fact that later they got married
but
went out on another date i guess and and
they eventually moved to new orleans
they went into the peace corps were in
brazil for two years in the 1970s and
then they came back settled on the farm
at this point my grandfather had was
retiring so you hold on
we gotta slow your roll a little bit you
can't just roll out marine corps nom
three tours
peace corps
that's kind of that's a freaking dynamic
you don't normally see
yeah yeah i think in addition to growing
up with stories of the marine corps i
grew up with stories of life in brazil
and this is in the 1970s in the amazon
region so it's very remote primitive
living
my mother was teaching
brazilian kids with
special needs
teaching them portuguese
and my dad was
somewhere in the realm of teaching
business and
skills to local community
people and how long were they down there
for two years two year tour and that's
in the 70s late 70s yeah did your dad
like start going a little bit hippie was
is that the scenario perhaps but when i
was my only living memory of him was not
as a hippie but i think there may have
been a stage there in the 1970s
post-vietnam
it can happen uh-huh
interesting
he's gonna be pissed if he just heard me
say he's like what a freaking hippie i
was helping out the locals
all right so then they get married and
at what point do they move back to
kansas around the time the peace corps
tour ended and i think my grandfather
was retiring moving to the lake of the
ozarks in missouri this beautiful
property the home was there i think my
parents wanted to start a family what
better place
the land was being farmed by an
associate of my father's grandfather's
and so they they settled and i think
shortly thereafter had me in 1980. you
were born in 1980 1980 check
and then what's growing up like you're
out there on the farm you're getting in
trouble for shooting with your bb
gun and stuff yeah we had a section of
woods we called the northeast corner
with a creek running through it and i
would go and just play there and try to
get lost what'd you have for brothers
and sisters i have a younger sister
she's seven years my younger
seven years and she she is a nurse and
uh when we get later into my story i
mean
she
quit her job to move down to dc to take
care of me
owe her a lot yeah
so she's seven years your junior though
so you were kind of like an only child
for a while for a little while i learned
how to
play by myself i didn't have close
neighbor i mean we have neighbors but
not necessarily with kids of my age i
learned how to entertain myself
and a lot of this was it was being
outside i i did like to read as a kid
but in the daytime i'm i'm outside
playing we had some dogs some cats some
pigeons that were in the barn that i was
aiming at
you know uh going on tractor rides
learning how to drive tractors playing
sports that was my childhood what sports
were you playing i started baseball
soccer gravitated towards soccer it
turns out i'm not that great at team
ball sports however the lessons that you
can learn from team ball sports really
come into play later
and so i'm very thankful that even
though my calling as an athlete was not
as a team ball sport player
nor was it in combatives i tried i tried
wrestling in middle school it was just
awful and then i had this idea of doing
boxing
so it was my
sophomore year in high school i went to
the local topeka golden gloves gym
and said you know i want to take some
lessons and so i remember my dad would
drive me there and back and eventually i
started just driving myself and i would
go and train in the local boxing gym
that resulted at one point in
going to a competition in kansas city
and kansas city's
a big deal when you're from a farm in
kansas
went to this
tournament in kansas city and i remember
there were hundreds of people in the
audience
it's kind of in a more
underdeveloped area of kansas city if
you will and
i remember seeing my opponent's older
brother
was just laying waste to someone on a
previous round
and so i think i wasn't just so nervous
i get in the ring it was three rounds
very amateur
in the first round he just laid into me
and i had this standing a count against
me
the second round was fairly even in the
third round i actually gave him
the standing eight count but it wasn't
enough because i just got whooped that
first round so i lost the fight
my dad was there watching
and afterwards we went and had some
had a meal had dinner and i just
remember him kind of it's okay he did a
good job and that was my that was my one
and only competitive boxing match the
thing you gotta remember dan is like
wrestling like if you go quote try
wrestling you're gonna get your ass
kicked
like
there's
it's not people think wrestling and
boxing they think it's like
uh a primal thing that you're just gonna
be able to do but man there's all kinds
of skills involved in that stuff this is
i started to think that if all you know
is winning
that's just not realistic
i've spent a lot more time in the not
winning realm than the winning realm and
i can tell you that when you're not
winning
it forces you to adapt
it forces you to look at what you're
doing how can you be doing things better
forces you to grow
challenges you
and i think there's a if sport is just
about character development which i
really think that's what it ultimately
is about then there's a lot to be
learned from not winning and
it's you need to seek out people who can
beat you in order to get better yeah
yeah so what did you play sports all
through high school i did soccer what
did you end up excelling at any of them
i was i was a varsity soccer player
defender because i didn't have good ball
skills even as a freshman i didn't
always start i was more of a bench
writer but i did earn a varsity letter
as a freshman and it started starting in
a sophomore and then was a was a varsity
player all four years my last
semester as a senior spring i knew i was
going to the naval academy
and we can get into the you know the
reasons of why i wanted to go there but
i i knew i was going and so i decided to
join the track team distance running i
thought i got to show up to the academy
ready to go ready to you know bust out a
1.5 mile run track had a two mile event
a one mile event
so i signed up and uh it it turns out in
soccer i was really good at running but
not so much kicking the ball or passing
it as a defender i just try to kick the
ball to one of my teammates who could
actually do something with it
but in track i was pretty good for one
season track athlete i ended up running
a sub five minute mile
had a i don't know a 10 32 mile
and so i thought endurance sports could
could have been my thing i just wasn't
exposed to it earlier i certainly wasn't
exposed to cross-country skiing as a kid
from a farm in kansas
so you you so you end up going to the
naval academy how did you get interested
in going to the naval academy
well i don't want to say that my father
pushed me in that direction in no way
whatsoever
i found he wrote me a letter when i did
get into the naval academy and he said
that his childhood dream was to go to
the naval academy but he didn't have the
grades
and didn't even apply
but i didn't go i didn't choose to go to
the military in the sense of
it feeling like a decision it just felt
like this is what i'm supposed to do
it really did i wanted to be a marine
did you apply to west point too i did
that academy west point was my backup
plan oh my god and i got into the best
one the naval academy
so i i just wanted to combine military
service with continuing my education and
i felt like
as
an officer i would have leadership
responsibilities and this would be i had
read books you know vietnam still
fascinates me and
probably a large part of this is due to
my father having been in the vietnam war
i would read anything i could get my
hands on about special operations in
vietnam infantry platoons marine corps
i was very very much
keen on
infantry small unit tactics i ended up
signing up for the local u.s naval sea
cadets program
there was a naval reserve unit in topeka
kansas
you drive there and it was kind of
modeled after reserves one weekend a
month you show up and you you drill
in the summers between your academic
years of high school
you get navy training it starts with
boot camp in great lakes so i went to
great lakes
the summer before my junior year of high
school for two years how old were you
i was 15 15 16. yeah two weeks not at
not an actual boot camp but it's very
much you're in great lakes you're
wearing dungarees you're marching around
you're getting yelled at and
i'm just in high school i don't remember
ever signing a waiver
but they had this training called
seal training i had to do one other
training before that's after that summer
of going to great lakes for boot camp i
went to amphibious school in virginia
and again i'm 15 or 16.
because i had to knock out one one of
these before i could be eligible for
seal training now in order to go to this
seal camp which is going to be the
following year that i would be eligible
this summer before my senior year
i'd have to take the the
the buds physical fitness test 500 yard
side stroke and
push-ups pull-up sit-ups and 1.5 mile
run so i started training for it and i
horrible horrible at swimming just
horrible but i somehow got under the
12-minute time or whatever it to cut off
barely
and so they they put me out to virginia
beach little creek for this uh two-week
camp and it starts with a what year is
this this would have been 97 1997 so
this is actually run by active duty team
guys
putting these high school kids
through this
washed down version of
hell week we had a hell night it started
off and i remember
that was a continuous it was a 24-hour
thing started sometime in the day and
sometime the next day go through the
night running with boats on your head
and i remember at one point running with
a boat on my head
i was on the left side of the boat and
an active duty navy seal
is just yelling at me because i don't
remember who it was but i don't i don't
i remember there was a chief blackburn
and he and this the particular
individual in this story is not chief
blackburn
i was slacking off and he just laid into
me about how i wasn't being a good
teammate and i'll never forget that it
just
cut right into me and
i came back we after that we got to
shoot mp5s we got to do the water
obstacle course in virginia beach it's
just as a high school kid i mean this is
amazing but
uh truth be told i didn't have perfect
eyesight and i just was horrible in the
water so when i did get into the naval
academy
my preference was for the marine corps
so
all that
hooyah seal stuff did get you like
oh it's totally brainwashed i was
brainwashed just sitting over here
listening to you tell that if i would
have been 15 it would have been a done
deal
it it was but i just didn't think how
bad was your idea
it was it needed to be correct it wasn't
it wasn't within 2040 it wasn't
certainly wasn't 2020.
at this point i didn't know about
corrective surgery i didn't that wasn't
even a thing i at the naval academy i
thought
i can go in the marine corps infantry be
a platoon leader a company commander and
so that's what i was leaning towards i
mean absolutely though when i went to
the naval academy
the seal program was extremely
intriguing to me i just didn't think i
would be eligible why would you set
yourself up just to be disappointed
chuck
so anything else from high school before
you roll out how hard was it to get uh
like all the
congressional recommendation and all
that stuff you know i don't think it's
that hard when you're applying to the
naval academy from kansas now it may be
different now
but if i was applying in virginia or
california or texas maryland virginia
the geographically proximate
states they're very competitive
but i had good grades you know one thing
i should say is by the time i was a
freshman in high school i was fortunate
enough to have this goal of the naval
academy
inside me i don't know how it got there
but it was there
and so
it then becomes a matter of well what do
i need to do to get into this place it's
going to be really hard
okay you gotta have
good grades check i'll study and get
good grades
gotta demonstrate some athletic talent
okay well i'm already doing that that's
just that was easy for me
leadership okay well i'll try to be a
sports team captain i'll try to run for
student government i'll do the c cadets
and uh that's kind of how i structured
it and so i think as my story unfolds
you'll see i tend to be a fairly
goal-oriented person but this is
something i think
is very
it's very important but not to force the
goals but when i have these goals
naturally
i feel like i can just be ignited
because this is driving me forward and
that's what was happening as early as my
freshman year and that's why i think i'm
very fortunate because if you make this
decision you want to go to a service
academy in your senior year of high
school it's too late you got to start
the process in your junior year you do
have to get a nomination from
either senator in your state or from
your congressional representative
and they're in coordinate they're in
communication with the academies and i
think the academies kind of lean them
towards the candidates that they are
already identifying and you have no
where did you hear about the naval
academy for the first time you don't
remember
it had to have been in the book i mean i
would just i remember watching movies
like predator and
just how come echo didn't end up at the
naval academy he was watching frederick
a lot more than you were oh yeah
probably was reading some books on
a platoon leader in the marine corps in
vietnam or something naval academy i
think
i think how it actually happened was at
one point i wanted to be a pilot but
then you know the eyesight thing it's
just it's not happening but to be a
pilot i mean
you start getting aware of the service
academy because to be a pilot you have
to go to a commissioning source
yeah so when you show up at the naval
academy for like plebe summer
you must be pretty used to this kind of
crap because
you've already been to boot camp you've
been had a bunch of teammates at
virginia beach for freaking
crushing you it really was not that big
of a deal and plebes summer is this six
week indoctrination it is not boot camp
but it is a service academy equivalent
of boot camp
your class is about 1200
incoming freshmen report in the middle
of the summer
july for about a six week
indoctrination into the military that
occurs and ends before the academic year
and on the note of the uh see cadets i
will say that at the end of my plea of
your freshman year at the naval academy
i was invited back
to be the class leader and i did do that
and that was just an awesome leadership
opportunity i could be the class leader
class leader of what of the incoming
secade class of high school students so
as a as a
now
done with my pleb year at the naval
academy
i'm the class oic
of this
group of high school kids coming from
all over the place
running through the same thing i had
been through
two years before at this point because
the other summer was plebe summer
and
how did you like
the naval academy well it was
it's like a love-hate relationship right
yeah you know there's this saying ihtfp
i hate this
place
but you know
in high school i had friends but i
didn't have
what i would call
deep connections with the people that i
was going to high school with and i i
definitely had friends but
when i was in the naval academy for the
first time i'm finding people that i
really see eye to eye with
i mean really quite
bonded in this way of looking at the
world the same way like
just
common interest common personality this
kind of thing but to a person and we
found each other weren't in the same
companies they all wanted to be selected
for seal training all of them was that
telling me
a couple of these individuals were
recruited swimmers all american high
school swimmers now they're varsity
swimmers as freshmen at the naval
academy
one
actually two were really good boxers and
i found that out the hard way trying to
spar with them a little bit in the ring
and then you know there was me
a farm kid from kansas and you know i
just was not comfortable in the water
the the
the truth of it is in pleap summer
i excelled physically in anything that
was on land but anytime we had to do
something in the water and this is maybe
two times a week you have to demonstrate
to the navy that you can float
that you can take off your camis
camouflage uniform when you're floating
and tie them and and inflate them to
help you float you have to demonstrate
that in the event that you fall off a
ship that you're not a total liability
that you can swim from one side of the
pool to the other
this is what you're doing in pleap
summer and on those particular days
we're marching it's hot out
i would have
knots of anxiety in my stomach
palpable
were you scared of failing or are you
scared of drowning
i was scared of the water i just didn't
have a lot of exposure now granted i had
gone to this seal see cadet seal thing
but there wasn't there was a little bit
in the water and that stuff petrified me
so i mean you know and
given what i ended up doing
one could call in to question my career
decision-making skills given that this
reality when i went to the naval account
i was just very very scared of the water
but by the end of this first year i had
met my circle of friends they all wanted
to pretty much to a person wanted to be
selected for seal training and so
are these guys all in your same class
same class so we're we're plebes
freshmen and they're just down for the
seals yeah and
how long does it take for you to
start thinking that in that direction as
well i would say by the end of my first
year there i no longer wanted to be a
marine and i wanted to be selected for a
seal program but i knew that i needed to
get in the water and start training get
parents what about your eyesight had you
now learned that you could get
corrective surgery that year's class
was able to get prk so that was a game
changer for me and it's like okay well
so
you weren't the class of 1999 no i was
class of 2002. so that in in the so you
watched the guys that were going to
graduate in 1999 or that had graduated
in 1999.
yes and who are going to buds and for
those
listening there are at the time 16
billets from the naval academy
graduating class to go to buds seal
training and
those
class those billets are split over
multiple classes but 16
graduate and get to go to buds and that
service selection happens around january
of your senior year so as a freshman in
january
i'm seeing who gets picked and i had
just heard that that some of these
individuals had prk to correct their
vision so that they may have had that
done a year before or something but but
that this is this is a game changer for
me
i just need to get better in the water
because uh i i was awful in addition to
being scared of the water borderline
scared just could not swim
so so do you start spending extra time
in the pool does someone grab you and
coach you and mentor you like how do you
start getting through this well i had a
good buddy who became a team guy and we
just started training together and uh
yeah i would figure it out myself you
know we work on john proofing we'd work
on swimming underwater 25 meters
something like that working on the
stroke
working i also had this goal of trying
to make the triathlon team because that
year the senior class out of those 16
bullets going to buds
i want to say five came from the
triathlon team so well
that's a team that could be good to make
it's not a varsity sport so therefore
you know you don't have to be recruited
it's a club sport let's get in the water
and start training and i was always a
very good runner and good at cycling so
i thought i'll train for triathlon and
along with my friend
we started training we would just go on
these adventures running running or
cycling with our fins strapped to a
backpack out to bay ridge or into the
chesapeake and just then go fin swim in
cold water come back
get on the bike
or run back to the academy
just doing fun adventures like that and
it just started pushing my limits what
were you majoring what did you major in
i chose to major in english the service
academies are geared towards science and
engineering and i am
they said
plebe year chemistry is a good
identifier of whether you will do well
in
engineering and science if you want to
major and they call it group one and
then group three is more the humanities
first semester chemistry no problem it
was a repeat of my high school
but second semester chemistry was new
stuff it just was over my head and so i
thought i had a very influential english
teacher in high school mr schultz
and in addition to my parents really
exposing me to reading and just i love i
still love to read i read a lot
this teacher really inspired me to to
want to be an english major if you if
this is what you like to do do it
and there's benefit from this i thought
you're gonna you learn about people you
learn about situations you develop
an ability to empathize or hopefully
with other people and communication
skills as well this is all very
important in the military so you decide
that you're going to study english while
you're at the naval academy correct and
are they like what part of english are
you studying like i mean that just seems
kind of strange it's english lit it just
was called english there but it really
it's it's not i mean i think they had
some writing classes or creative writing
this kind of thing but really it's the
study of literature and
my favorite class was a class on
hemingway and as a kid i had read
hemingway and i i read a farewell to
arms
for whom the bell tolls and these are
books very much about war in the wartime
experience
so
as you're going through at what point
are you
starting to compete and you're starting
to look at hey how am i actually going
to get selected because you know you say
there's 16 billets and that is it's as
competitive as it gets to get one of
those 16 billets what do you think you
did that was able to make you stand out
and actually get selected
i remember plebe year we were in an
auditorium i think this is during pleap
summer when the whole class 1200 people
is assembled and they're saying who
wants to be an aviator
600 hands go up who wants to be on a
ship 600 out of roughly 12 1200 you know
okay i'm estimating right who wants to
be on a ship and you know a few hundred
who wants to be a navy seal and like
200 150 hands go up easy
but by the time it comes around to the
junior year we really got to start
making things happen
i feel like there were maybe 60 or 70 in
my class that were kind of
very much gunning for this you have to
do a screener weekend in order to get
ready for
mini buds mini buds is
a three-week program
prior to your senior academic year
so you'd go there to coronado did you go
to mini buds i did i had to do the
screener weekend in the fall of my
junior year
and in that you're ranked based on a pft
physical fitness test you go through
about two days of just
hazing essentially from the seniors the
upper class who have gone to many buds
as if that really qualifies them to do
that but and then from that if you
survive
most badasses drunk maybe the mini buds
but at the time you know you're revering
these they've been the mini buds and
some of them are going to go to buds and
if you get through all this then you can
go to mini buds and then ostensibly
you're ranked out of that and then it
goes into your senior year you do an
another fitness test that gets ranked
you do a pure evaluation
who do you want to go to buds with who
do you not want to go to budget so you
got selected to go to mini buds i did
yep and and how was mini buds
yeah i thought it i thought it i did
well it's three weeks long yeah this is
my first time going to coronado
california and i fell in love with the
place being from kansas just like this
this is awesome we had the weekends off
i think we did a hell night similar very
similar to the sea cadet thing i did
except now it's in coronado as opposed
to little creek virginia
and then it was just exposure you know
in high school i'd been shooting mp they
let us shoot mp5s and uh i don't think
we even did got to do anything that cool
in mini buds i think some of it was just
going out to la posta and doing some
land navigation in the heat
but it was just a really good time with
my buddies from the naval academy and
then after that i got to go to navy dive
school because i had done a screener for
that and that's in panama city florida
and i think that really was helpful for
me given my
my uh insecurities in the water to go to
dive school
five weeks in panama city florida
learning how to dive twin eighties
how how long was it five weeks it was
five weeks so that summer before my
senior year it was just for me it was
just the best summer mini buds for three
weeks dive school for five weeks come
back for senior year with a dive bubble
not that's i mean just in the school
like that's kind of a big deal to have a
dive bubble oh you were kind of a badass
and you get done with all that and now
this is like september
2001 right this is like september 11
2001 it's gonna go down right before or
as you start your senior year yeah i
remember september i'll never forget
that day i had class a late morning
class
and i went out for a run that morning
and
out outside of the campus outside of the
yard
and
as a senior you're allowed to do that i
came back to the gate and
they wouldn't let me in i didn't have my
id
you don't need to run with an id why are
they asking for my id
and then i came to find out what had
happened i went back to the dorm where
we all live i changed into my uniform
went to class and you're seeing
seeing the replays i didn't see it live
but
things
totally totally changed i mean that day
the academy was on lockdown
we didn't know what was happening
we heard the pentagon had been attacked
of course the towers in new york and
for me
this some really
drove home
this reality if i get selected for seal
training and i'm not gonna know until
january
i'm gonna be directly involved in the
nation's response to this we're this is
for real it's now we're at war
and
there's a decision that anybody wanting
to go to buds has to make its
this
decision of what are you going to put as
your second choice
and the theory amongst the majority of
my friends in fact i think all of them
was well if you want to demonstrate that
you want to be a seal you need to put
ships as number two because that's the
best way to laterally transfer
you're going to have to go to newport
rhode island for surface warfare officer
school you'll do a tour in the fleet and
then you can put in your package you can
come to buds two years later
for me
i was thinking about this long and hard
because you're trying to game you want
to get one of those billets but you
don't know if you will it's very
competitive at this point there's
probably 45 guys that are up for this
and these guys are like varsity
wrestlers varsity swimmers
water polo
badasses yeah destroying the pst they
got a 4.0 gpa
it's like just studs yeah so for me i
thought about this and i put the marine
core as number two you have to go into
an interview board
and this happens in the fall and this
board was happening after 9 11
and it's comprised of
senior
seal officers
mid middle range seal officers a couple
lieutenants at the academy at the time
and then some senior enlisted seals
so this is intimidating it's a panel of
maybe eight to ten team guy officers and
enlisted that you know you just you
don't see a lot of tridents at the
academy so when you do it's just
intimidating dude when i went to boot
camp there was one seal there
and like
i saw him years later like probably two
two or three years later he he had
gotten out and was going coming back in
and so he was at boot camp like going
going through some basic like
wickets to get reinstated in the navy i
need to try to and you know i was like
oh my god it's a freaking real seal
and
when i met him years later
totally good dude but if you would ask
me what was the
height and approximate weight of this
guy that you saw that was a seal in boot
camp i would have said oh he's probably
let's call it probably 6'5
260.
because that's what in my mind that's
what he was and i met him in real life
and he was like
like 5 11
you know 190 you know and that that's
legit like i legitimately thought that
he was like that
badass and i was young i mean but still
that uh when you're that when you're
young you see that that freaking chicken
for the first time you're like oh damn
so you're going to this board with eight
of these dudes yeah one of the highest
ranking officers in 06 a seal captain
and i don't know anything about the ins
and outs of the seal teams but this is
intimidating and everything
everything seems to
you know
depend upon my performance right here
right now in front of these people and
so i just remember standing outside the
room that the guy in front of me is in
there you know he comes out and and i'm
like how was it you know he's like
like shaking his head like it's tough so
i go in there and uh
you know they they asked me
i think they were leading me down so why
are you an english major do you write do
you do you like poetry do you drink
poems
and i'm trying to say well
sir this is about uh it's about learning
of other people and understanding
situations and developing communication
skills and i think that'll serve me
really well in in the community if i'm
if i have the honor of being selected
then they they said
your second choice you're not putting
down service warfare
what's going on with that
and i said well
we're at war
i'd rather be in the marine corps if i
can't go to buds
i'd rather lead a infantry platoon
at the time i didn't know i i think
looking back that's probably the right
answer
and i really did
i don't know if the marines would have
taken me the rumor also was you put them
a second they're not gonna they're not
gonna thank you i've heard that that's
like a real catch 22 for guys at the
academy because they want to go in the
seal teams but there's so few billets
but if you put marine core as number two
the marines are like are you kidding me
your marine corps should be number one
later
so that's a bummer
but that i've heard that as well yeah
and and truth to be told i think i'm not
gonna gain this i'm just gonna
rank my choices and and honestly there's
a lot of things i'd rather do than be on
a ship and so
i'm either gonna make it or not into the
into buds and maybe the marines will
take me maybe they won't but i remember
exiting the interview thinking i have no
idea how that went it probably felt like
it was forever but it was probably half
an hour and did you know nothing i'm
just sitting here like laughing you know
nothing about anything i know they were
in
retrospect they probably knew the people
they wanted
and maybe a couple were on the fence i
don't know where i stacked in there but
they probably were just screwing they'd
probably laugh after after you leave
they're probably did you meet any of
these guys later in the teams absolutely
yeah did they debrief you at all did
they even remember you
the company officer at the academy was
there and you know he's he's still in
and you know we've uh i have not asked
him specifically about that but they uh
i i was i was ranked fine i found out
afterwards
so you were ranked fine you find out in
january
that's when you find out what where
you're going
that it yes there's a day called service
selection day
you're gonna
go into your company officers room every
company there are 30 companies at the
academy the whole every company is
comprised of all four years
and that company has a company officer
from either the active duty navy or
marine corps and then a company senior
enlisted from the navy or marine corps
so you go into the company officer's
office and
he's
or she is going to tell you
what you've been assigned and this is
your fate
you don't get
this is what you're doing that's not a
debate no you don't get to say well this
or that and if you're assigned to a ship
later that night you get to choose and
it's
somewhat of a lottery system i think it
actually depends on class rank
you can choose what ship you want to go
on
but you don't get to contest the fact
that you were assigned
surface warfare
so i go in there and he's printing off a
certificate that's going to tell me my
fate and his back is to me i just
remember it's just my heart is pounding
what did you think your chances were
the tithe had about 50 50 50 50.
so i go in there and the first thing he
said it was
don't worry you're fine
what does that mean
you got what you wanted
so i remember just feeling absolute
relief
and then about
maybe
five minutes later it was like
i'm going to buds
whoa
and now i'm already starting to feel
this apprehension because
hell week
second phase
water
i gotta get ready
uh how many of your buddies
didn't get picked up
like your good buddies
one of my how was that whole freaking
relationship thing because you know
there's like two guys that were like
faster than you and there was another
guy that was smarter than you and
another guy that was like a
better wrestler and you're just going
yeah
by and large most of my best friends got
a bullet but one of my best friends did
not and
one of my other buddies who did
the guy that i was going on the
adventures with we came up to his room
later that day
and he started crying in front of us i
won't forget that either
we all wanted this so bad but i think it
was it was more than
necessarily the job it was this is what
your buddies are doing you want to be
with your teammates it's so
yeah it's a challenge and you're
intrigued by that but it's about
teamwork and he was crying and man i
felt bad for him and you know
going on to buds
wanting to stay in touch with him not
knowing how to navigate how much do i
tell about what i'm doing
or do i try to protect his feelings and
not really you know that's it's you know
this or that or whatever
but i am proud to say
that later on when i went to a team
another friend of mine we spoke to the
commanding officer
and
who apparently had
good rapport with the detailer
and uh we said there's this guy that's
the individual who did not get the
billet
that year and he was able to lateral
transfer and he is the commanding
officer
of of a team a team
right now that's right which is awesome
yeah i mean uh for me when i was in when
i was tasking a bruiser stoner and leif
both those guys didn't get picked up out
of the academy
and
they both had to go to the fleet and do
the whole lat transfer thing and you
know it's all just
man like you said it's your fate is in
the hands of all these
different things and you can push it and
that's a great story you know it's a
great story when guys actually stick
with it and go to the fleet and do that
lateral transfer thing
uh that's
that's a game i did glad i didn't have
to play yeah in many ways you were smart
but i will say i remember there was in
the plebier the individual who did not
get the bill who is now doing quite well
in the teams
who you know
uh he
in freshman year we were talking about
what are you gonna
decide for your major you know you don't
have to declare until the springtime i
was like i'm going to do english and he
goes i think i'm thinking computer
science
and so he he chose computer science and
his grades were not the best and so
it's for me this was english was such a
good
choice the clutch
i could i happen to be someone who likes
to read and i can
maybe not always read all of the book
but still write a decent paper focus on
my math and science and engineering
classes to try to get at least to be in
those classes to try to have good grades
because they are evaluating everything
and part of that is your grades
so september 11th goes down you get
picked up you're in your final prep you
must have been feeling decent about the
water now that you passed navy dive
school yes i'm much more confident in
the water
i felt like
i had improved a lot
and i knew that anything on land
i'm going to be just given the
perspective of
being borderline afraid of the water
that i could use this to my advantage
i've overcome a fear
i'm used to being afraid of the water
there's actually a strength in that
learning how to overcome something what
i did was i walked up to the water's
edge just about every day there at the
academy for four years
and literally immersed myself in this
environment that i
am uncomfortable in
and
come to find later
i had a distinct apprehension
of jumping out of airplanes as well and
so seal stands for sierra and land sea
and air were not my thing
but the processes of overcoming this
fear of the water
serve i think have served me quite well
and so there's this
i think inner strength
that can come from
approaching
situations that make you uncomfortable
you get through this you take it one
small step at a time work on something
there's always something you can work on
do one thing today do another thing
tomorrow over time
this will accumulate and grow yeah i've
thought about that too like uh
you're jumping out of airplanes you're
fast roping you're repelling you're
diving you're diving at night all these
things that are a little bit sketchy if
you're not comfortable with them and
look the first time you jump out of an
airplane even if like for me i thought
it was going to be fun but it's still a
little bit sketchy first time i fast
roped like hey this seems like it's
going to be fun but it's still a little
bit sketchy first time you repel off the
tower seems like it's going to be fun
but it's still a little bit sketchy
well you're building up sort of the
mental protocol to be in a fearful
situation and just like proceed anyways
which i think is really good for the
first time you're going into combat like
oh okay yeah i know those little
butterflies no factor i'm going to push
through them that's probably a probably
a pretty good reason just to do those
things in the first place of course you
sounds like you did it more than i did
yeah i think the first step here is
acknowledging what's going on no i okay
this is the situation i'm uncomfortable
in the water
okay yeah check
let's let's come up with a plan of
action now but yeah going into buds i
remember i graduated may
24 2002 from the naval academy and my
report date
at naval special warfare training
command buds is late june 2002 so i had
about a month off we got to choose
of the 16 of us who were gonna go to
buds with and in what order and it was
split over three classes
and i was in the group that
was gonna go first and so we weren't
gonna have the stories from and i
thought this this is actually probably
good i i was happy with the first
first off the deck because we're not
going to see
naval academy classmates who are further
along
who maybe can give some wisdom
but they're also through various stages
and and i just i'd rather just be the
first one to go and so that worked out
well there's a definite like the naval
academy guys usually do well at buds and
if they quit they're just like hated by
everyone because they took a billet they
took one of those 16 billets and
everyone just can't believe that you got
this opportunity and freaking blew it
like i mean the enlisted guys like i
didn't care i mean when i was an
enlisted guy going through i didn't care
if somebody would quit for whatever
reason i was like whatever but naval
academy guys they take that real
personal there's some pressure but i
also think that can be an advantage i
went out to
coronado
we the sixth so there's actually there's
gonna be six five and five in those
three groups so i'm gonna be going with
six five other classmates from the naval
academy we were packed into an apartment
in imperial beach three bed three
bedrooms two to a room
like 200 per person a month got it for
rent
and
there was no way i could come back to
that apartment having quit no way how
could i how could i do that so you're
putting yourself in a situation of your
16 quit
one damn not in my group yeah
but you're putting yourself in a
situation where
external
factors you know peer relationships this
kind of thing can actually although it
could be conceived or construed as
adding pressure i think it actually
made me you know it
at these kind of you're at your breaking
point point moments
this was maybe just a subliminal nudge
in the direction of do not
do not succumb do not quit
push through let's go i was like so
detached from people quitting i didn't
even understand what was happening like
people were just quitting i was like i i
was saying this the other day like they
didn't seem like human to me like i i
they didn't seem like a human like oh
this guy i didn't i didn't picture a
person with like hopes and dreams and i
can't believe they just did that and
they they joined the navy and now
they're quitting like oh gosh what i was
just like oh this person's just a
non-human thing that just like is moving
on and they're not part of our what
we're doing and so i wasn't even i can't
even name i can only name one guy that
quit and he was my boat crew leader and
he was my book crew later in hell week
but that's the only everyone else was
just like gone i just never even thought
about them never even and i never had
thoughts like oh i
you know this guy's my friend so i never
thought like that i was like oh we're
just gonna i'm just doing this oh what
do you want us to climb those rocks she
wants to jump in the water or whatever
like
like i was like you said
oh maybe you mentioned real quick i said
well you know i'd have to go through all
that stuff and they look at me like yeah
maybe you're smarter and i was like no
and my mind was like no i was dumb i was
just like oh i'm going in the navy i
want to be a seal they tell me to do
something i'm going to do it like that
was my attitude
so
so and it might have been beneficial it
seems like it was beneficial but it also
disconnected me from
even really any recognition of
how hard seal training is because to me
i was like there was just two groups of
people me and my buddies and everyone
else and we didn't know them and they
just went away and then we were all
going to the teams it was like oh yeah
we'll go to the teams so it was almost
like this weird like now when i hear
some of the statistics and you know more
about it and and you know that guys that
are
went to the naval academy and guys that
were you know
uh uh
freaking division one swimmers and
division one wrestlers and division one
football players and they all quit
and like i just didn't even
i i just thought there were a bunch of
guys that just didn't want to be here
and i do so that was that kind of crazy
yeah i remember someone giving me advice
or i collected along the way three
pieces of advice number one
in hell week eat like it's your job
don't ever let up eat no matter how
tired you are eat eat eat
second was
give 70 effort 100 of the time
try not to have to ever give 100
[Music]
but a good 70 effort 100 of the time
sustainable
and then
third was
don't get close to anybody because you
don't know if they're going to quit i'm
wondering if when your boat crew leader
quit if that affected you
i hear i hear when it off it sounds like
it didn't it but i you hear stories
about when an officer quits
three or four people go with that person
yeah i forget what get my buddy gif who
i went through hell week we he was on
here the other day and we were talking
about he he just said like he was
laughing he's like you just looked at
him like all right whatever and we just
like carried on i was like yeah no
factor i was too like i was too crazy i
guess i was too just weird i guess or
crazy or something
uh did you have any challenges during
buds like when you got to pool comp how
was that did you have any challenges
with the with the
five and a half nautical mile swim or
anything like that
you know i think
what i saw in buds with my class was no
matter how gifted a person was there was
probably going to be something at some
point that was going to
challenge them and one of the one of my
classmates this individual from the
naval academy who i had known for four
years at this point was just a just a
stud in buds and there was one day at
the very end for whatever reason the the
obstacle course rope with the the the
low wall the one you have the high wall
you ascend the rope and then kind of
roll over the rope was wet and he just
had a really hard time i hope i hope i'm
not if he's listening i hope he's i'm
not bringing up some bad memories but
btsd for me you know i actually did
quite well in pool week i
maybe haven't gone to dive school really
high school had to have helped me and i
remember
in dive school the first just feeling
really uncomfortable breathing
underwater just was weird you know
but by the time second phase dive phase
of buzz comes around that was normal
the double hose regulator was new
because we were using a single hose and
dive school but
yeah you know in the aqualung aqua
master yeah
yeah i was just there was one
evolution though and it's it's
life-saving
i forget if that was pre or post holic i
want to say it was pre hell week i think
it's pre
we had some
large instructors who had weight belts
on and
they bring it in i failed the first time
did your world come crashing down
yeah i it was just
he was just taking me under and and the
second time i failed and it was like the
third time it's i'm thinking you know
i'm sitting in the like that wall that
line of shame yeah
where you failed and now you have to
this is your chance you know i'm
thinking like
is this it
so i uh
i just really tried to focus on
the procedure and trying to do it and
number one like what i was failing was
the fact that this instructor was under
water so i like number one thing is keep
this person's head above the water i
don't care if i'm drinking water if i'm
underwater the whole time his head needs
to be above the water the entire time
and uh i get to the wall and it was a
pass i was just like we'll take it
yeah and i i hope i didn't come across
like buds was easy for me
because i mean i failed to run i failed
to swim uh
i failed pool comp and actually here's
the funny thing
for life saving i got so ready for life
saving i was going i was like hostile i
was like oh i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna
fight some dudes and it was like that
back then i don't feel like that when
you went through it sounds like it was
it was a fight like you're gonna fight
this person and so i was super amped up
for that i went out got first in line
and in pool comp i failed pool comp on
friday and and over the weekend me and
my buddy who's now an active duty master
chief
we he failed too and we spit i don't
know how we did this i don't know how
this was legal i don't know if it was
legal we spent the weekend in the dip
tank with with charge twin innings i
don't know how we got them and we just
freaking pool come to each other in
four feet of water like we're standing
outside the dip tank i'm in the dip tank
he's standing there just ripping my face
and we did that for the whole weekend
the whole weekend we did that i got on
on monday morning i went in there
the instructor came down and this
instructor ended up being an admiral but
he came down and as soon as i saw him
coming out i ripped off my own face mask
and spit out my mouthpiece like you can
bring it dude and sure enough he was
like dude this guy is obviously very
confident and you know he messed me up
but then he was just like you know
passed so
uh
i kind of would go a little bit extra on
some of these things but but i don't
want to make it sound like uh it was
easy for me because like i said in fact
i failed to run i failed to swim not
only that i can promise you i never want
to run i never want to swim i never won
an o course i was like in the middle of
everything
and that was about that was about all i
had too like when i failed to run it was
because i didn't i tried to pace myself
a little bit
and failed so my only way to pass a run
was to run as hard as i possibly could
the entire time 100 yeah not
100 no it was 100 100 that's how i had
to do it to pass a run to pass a swim to
pass everything uh so your only big
challenge though was
life-saving
life-saving but there was a moment in
the beginning stages of hell week where
and i can tell the story
i was at
a decision point
at my i i would say my breaking point it
and a lot of this was because
frustration oh dude they're gonna get
you somehow frustration with physical
pain can be a really potent combination
and hell week you know starts on a on a
sunday you know it's gonna end friday
you're going to not sleep once until
sometime on wednesday all these thoughts
are kind of going through my head 70 of
my class 80 are going to quit they're
not going to make it am i going to be
one of the ones who gets through all
these looking around you're in an
isolation room waiting for this thing to
start just all these thoughts going
through your head
you know what i was thinking at that
time just like
wait when's this gonna start i want
pizza
so you're having all these advanced
thoughts dude like just
you know i'm thinking all this stuff and
uh you know don't who knows who's gonna
quit don't get close to anybody
and we break out and it's just chaos and
form up the longest smile you go all the
way down with the boats on your head to
the bottom end of the silver strand
racing
you're tired it's it's not
it's not comfortable by any means but uh
you know at this point it's like we're
in i'm in this i'm you're you're in it
you're in it and so all that anxiety and
buildup and apprehension has kind of
dissipated because i'm just in this now
we're forming up for the second race
it is part of the longest mile
with the logs logs or you know the
sectioned telephone poles and
my team steps up to a government pickup
trucks receiving our log and
this thing was just
insanely heavy i don't know what was
going on with it it wasn't old misery
i don't know what was going on it felt
like it was waterlogged yep it probably
could have been waterlogged and maybe
the instructors knew maybe they didn't i
don't know they knew
and me i just remember we had one of the
guys in the boat and i guarantee you
every single person under that log it
remembers this log
it was just so heavy i mean and you know
what a log is supposed to weigh you've
done this stuff before and immediately
groaned and there was a guy on the boat
team who had been through
i think three days of hell week before
in a pre you know two years before gone
to the fleet come back and immediately
was saying
this log is a career ender
this is not good so we we received the
the brief you know log carry north bust
em go it races on
and just all the teams in the class were
just out of sight you couldn't hear or
see the second to last place team even
you know this is bad this is wait so you
guys are so far so far back to the last
one you can't even see the second to
last place team i mean like the whole
class is just god and we are all by
ourselves at the
last place so of course the instructors
descended upon us like a pack of wolves
you know with their megaphones and hurry
up step it out move it out let's go
and then there was this instructor in my
face and this
person had a unique ability to really
get under my nerves
and he's telling me he's going to kick
me out of the program we need to step it
out i'm at the far left end of the log
are you the boat crew leader yes
far left end of the log
where the weight tends to collect
and the person to my right it just
you know 10 15 20 minutes into this i
have no conception of time but we're
into this race now we're in last place
and it seemed like his arms there just
wasn't much so you can feel the increase
of the weight and i'm at the far left
end of the log so it felt like i was
carrying two people's worth of weight on
the far left and this log that was so
heavy
i mean it felt it literally felt like my
arms were going to just rip my
rip out of the shoulder sockets my
biceps were
totally on fire i mean every
step was just
horrendous and i started just
succumbing to
self-doubt frustration thinking
long-term thought like
how am i gonna this is i'm just a few
hours into hell week how am i gonna make
it like to friday friday seems
impossibly far away and this log is
destroying my body
this is not good it's not good i worked
years to get to this point and
yeah things are just unraveling fast
this is not a good start to health we're
only a few hours in middle of the night
and uh there was this moment where
i remember looking up into the skies
we're struggling to advance this log
forward through the soft sand in last
place and just thinking
i can't do this it's just too much and i
was frustrated because these instructors
and they don't you know i just wanted to
scream this isn't fair
this is not this log is not
the right kind of weight it's not a fair
race
but i couldn't say that
and they didn't know or led on to their
knowledge that this log was too heavy so
at this critical point
where i just out of frustration i was
just about to walk away i remember
i just had this idea of like playing
this game
and
it's all in my mind
but i could quit but first you know take
a few more steps
i take those steps but then
okay just keep playing this game okay
take a few more steps okay i've done
that let's just keep playing this game
and so
i just got in that rhythm and then i
started you know yelling some
encouragement to the team and
let's go let's go let's go and they
probably wanted me to shut up
but this game i learned a lesson like
okay you gotta when you have these
situations to push you to your limit you
may have long-term goals you know i
wanted to be a navy seal and all but it
seemed like really far away and as i un
you know think about this and
unpack this experience what i have
learned is that
a way to get your mind away from these
long-term thoughts
that can only be discouraging is to just
focus on mechanics and procedure and
process support the log with my arms
advance it with my team one step at a
time that's all i need to be thinking
about right you know and just you learn
that i learned that in that night
right then and there in that rate yeah
of course we finished last place and we
got hammered
but because you know it pays to be a
winner and they want to drive home this
lesson that
losing in combat has severe consequences
you need to find ways to win there was
no way in hell we were going to win
under this log but
that punishment occurred the log was
away we were just i don't know doing air
squats or bear cr whatever it was it was
better than being under that log and i
knew that i just got through that there
was nothing
nothing this week that can be that bad
and nothing was that bad and i remember
laying in the surf zone
surf torture sessions all i would need
to do was just think man this is rest
at least i'm not under that log my whole
perspective it changed i got through it
i learned that lesson you just focus on
one step at a time and advancing it in
one one
but uh
this
i think every person who gets through
hell week at some form whether they
process this consciously or not but
you have to break down long-term massive
challenges into increments things that
you can do right now that add up over
time to get through a very difficult
situation that lesson was very
valuable for me no that's a that's a
good one and
like i said from my perspective it was
just like
i never even was thinking that far in
advance i was like what carry this log
cool got it you know i was too uh too
much of a knuckle dragger to to process
these kind of uh
these kind of
big picture strategic thoughts about my
life yeah you know maybe i'm prone to
overthinking and so there is something
to be said for just
just doing it and not think you know
just
do what you got to do you know i
remember thinking when i was in hell
week i was like oh it's going to feel so
good to go to sleep like it was almost
like my anticipation was like oh it's
going to feel good so cool to stay awake
for so long because imagine how good
it's going to feel to fall asleep when
in a week that's going to be so cool
it's going to feel so good they'll just
like lay down and i was kind of excited
about
the prospect of having stayed awake for
so long but then i got to go to sleep
the only way you can get to
to get that
much pleasure in sleeping is to stay
awake for that longer otherwise it's
just kind of a pain to go to sleep it's
like a waste of time it feels like it's
like uh
bad um
so thankfully
you made it through how many people
started in your buds class do you
remember oh we had
when we classed up i believe it was 196.
that number sticks in my mind it seems
like a pretty uh what class number it
was class 242 so
june of 2002 we classed up hell week was
late august 2002 summer hell week
so the surf torture sessions weren't
that bad they just leave you in longer
but again it's just rest they adjust
yeah and uh i believe we graduated 26
original but we had rollbacks along the
way yeah
uh
you get done so that's those were your
major challenges a little bit of life
savings two big challenges yeah um
you get done
and
you get assigned to a team what team you
end up going to west coast team team one
so you end up going to team one did you
want to go to the west coast yeah i
chose that i had
you had that coronado on your mind yeah
you know being from kansas i've been
east coast at the naval academy and you
know i
the thing is when you get to a team
nobody cares
that you went through hell week
nobody cares nobody cares you haven't
tried it these things i've been working
for for years
they no longer matter did you get your
trident after sqt yes
so so september 2003 i reported that
that west coast team in october 2003 as
a new guy
so you show up and you get put right
into platoon
no the policy at that team at that time
was
and and they were the detailing was a
little off in the sense that they were
just a few months away and
ended up doing a surge deployment
so
i
the team had to do a surge deployment to
ira i think
i kind of forget the particulars but
maybe more platoons were needed is this
an o4 yes and you are a team one yes and
you went on deployment yes in less than
four months after arriving you went on
deployment in the
uh what what time of year
january 04 i believe there was some kind
of a surge happening within the
community
and so i got to that team they were
already well through their work up and
so the policy there were several of us
junior officers who were just kind of
floating around and the policy was not
to put the third officer in a platoon
at that team at that time so did you go
on deployment yeah i did i deployed to
the pacific okay and uh
i was at team
seven and team one relieved us that's
why yeah so i if you would have gone to
iraq you would have high fived with me
in iraq because i was getting ready to
head home i was not in that group i was
i was bummed you know when you think
at the naval academy that you've now
been selected to go to buds 911 just
happened this is for real we're going to
war you go through buds
hell week etc land warfare
everything sqt you get to a team
you're deploying to war i did not
realize
that some platoons deploy
to
non-combat environments
even when
there is combat
going on and that was a surprise to me
not exactly what i expected
but i'm a new guy and so you just you go
where you're told and a lot of people
may not realize this but
platoons don't often get to control
where they deploy even the commanding
officer of the team doesn't get to
control that there's a
there's a
strong element of chance in all this
stuff and
you have that's why the best thing you
can do is get to a team do a good job do
the best you can keep going on
deployment and hopefully you get in the
right place at the right time the better
you do the better reputation you have
the better chance you will have
but it's still only a chance
um
so you did you do a full six months in
the pacific it was nine months oh dang
nine months in the pacific stage uh at a
guam doing a lot of exercises with
various countries i mean
you got to we got to do some cool
training
which for me
was actually
new training
especially in terms of
urban combat and movement through houses
and among structures so that was
something i hadn't been exposed to
because i hadn't done the work up so
getting to do that with a platoon with
simunition and this kind of thing was
was really good training i thought
so you get done with that deployment now
you get put as an assistant platoon yeah
correct commander yes so you're still at
team one yeah so this is now 2004 gonna
be deploying 2005. assistant platoon
commander same team
and how's this
yep it assistant platoon commander i'm
still a new guy
you know you're in this position as a
junior officer in my situation not being
prior enlisted like you were that
you're
in terms of not only age but experience
in the teams you're just outranked even
though
maybe technically on the uniform there's
a rank
so
it's a difficult position to navigate
sometimes i think
you want to go into this with some
humility with asking questions
i found that
junior officers in the team sometimes
and i
i think i can put myself in this
category try to cover
up some of their insecurities not
knowing things not having the experience
by acting as if they do no yeah which is
a big mistake
yeah in retrospect you can you can see
you know that people can see through
this but at the time you don't
necessarily realize that
and
so
maybe you're
reluctant to ask advice or ask someone's
opinion but i actually learned
that this is a wonderful opportunity to
show someone that you value their
opinion you ask hey
in in the in the locker room where the
cages are how you setting up your kit
just pick their brain and i mean this is
a i think this is a good a good thing
for anybody in any organization when
you're new is just ask the people who
know what's going on
what do you recommend and this this
creates a sense of
buy-in i think the
the fact that you value their opinion
that's that's useful so i tried i tried
to approach it
from a position of humility but
as an
assistant platoon commander your primary
responsibilities are learn tactics learn
small unit leadership and then do
administrative functions for the platoon
and support the platoon commander yeah
and i mean even though i was a prior
enlisted guy i mean i still would ask
the
team like the guys hey what do you how
do you think we should do this what do
you think we should do
where should we insert what do you think
about this platform over here i would
always do that even if
even when i was the more experienced and
sometimes even the most experienced and
i learned that from one of my platoon
commanders who was a prior enlisted guy
who had more experience than any of us
who asked us hey what do you think how
do you think we should do this and
that's you know i got to just steal his
leadership uh techniques for when i be
for when i was put in charge but i
always give that advice you know if you
there's no sense in acting like you know
what you're doing because
everybody not only do they see through
it but they don't expect you to know
everything they're like hey you've been
here for three months bro we don't
expect you to know how to run this drill
or how to plan for this mission it's
okay
we do and we can all work together to
figure this out
uh
any standout memories from that workup
getting ready to deploy
you know
my memories are of
the people and
in particular two
who are no longer here and that's just
something that i'll always take away
from that platoon
one
one was
killed in in the extortion
helicopter crash and another on an
operation
a few years ago
so that's that's tough i you know i
really just
i think about those guys a lot
i
i would say
one of my
leadership failures in this phase was
along the lines of being in that
position of
you're younger you don't have as much
experience you're falling into wanting
to be
one of the one of the guys one of the
you know buddies and and i i would say
you know this is probably something that
everybody deals with
in in
the junior officer ranks of the teams
you
want to be liked you want to be buddies
you know going out and this kind of
thing with the guys and i you know i did
that and and i don't have any regrets
but i think
for me one of the hardest
i think
hardest positions i could have put
myself was to be able to make a decision
that's that may be right but not popular
now i wasn't the platoon commander but
as an aoic it's pretty easy to get into
that situation of like okay you're
supposed to support the platoon
commander but yet you are
buddies with the guys it can be sort of
like you know between a rock and a hard
place kind of a situation i think that
was a leadership takeaway that i had
from that that platoon and we ended up
deploying
to the pacific again this was uh more
directly locate in one specific aao and
it was doing
foreign internal defense with host
nation forces and
we were dispersed kind of in a satellite
model and
it was a long deployment there was
definitely some leadership challenges
guys in the platoon they want to go to
iraq they want to go to afghanistan at
this point
but we're we're on this deployment to
the
to the pacific theater and and so yeah
there's some leadership challenges for
sure in that environment yeah and for a
while
the seal teams was rotating
like so you'd do half your deployment in
the pacific and then go into iraq or
afghanistan for another three months but
eventually people said that's not a good
move either and it really isn't i mean
it really it just doesn't make
it
it's like the fair fairy
comes up with those kind of ideas
because it's more fair to get and you
know you you feel you feel it you know
you're like well this guy these guys
want to go get in the fight so that
seems like the fair thing to do but
unfortunately it's the fair fairy
doesn't always have the best ideas even
though it seems fair it's not smart yeah
and and the argument is well okay
six months is too long to be in combat
so we can relief in place and the people
who really want to go to you know but
then
you're bringing in people that don't
have ao expertise it's just
yeah i agree i
so at this point now i've done two
deployments as a junior officer
i have not been to iraq or afghanistan
and
people who had gone through
buds with at this point have started
deploying to iraq or oef in afghanistan
and they're
going on combat operations you know the
stuff that we train to do we train to do
all of it
but
the
what really pushes your training in
the ultimate test of your training
applied overseas is
what you could be doing in iraq given
the state of things at that time was
what you could be doing in iraq or
afghanistan and so yeah i was feeling
well to be honest uh a bit frustrated
because as a junior officer you're gonna
get your aoic deployment
your oic deployment
in platoons
and if you're either in a platoon or
you're not
and i've when i first showed up at the
team and i'm not in a platoon
that sucks
it sucks you're in a platoon you're not
and you're gonna get two platoons
and
then maybe a task unit commander to her
but okay certainly not as quite as
operational
so
yeah man i got one more to go and
see i was i was a little bit frustrated
to be honest and then now
and i don't i don't want to come across
as bitter i'm just trying to be honest
about how i felt at the time well
what kind of human beings
try and go through all this to go
to the seal teams guys that want to go
to war
so when you do a nine month deployment
with no war and then you know you go on
a six-month deployment no war and you
know you've got limited opportunities in
the rest of your
career it's gonna be
i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't
want
the type of person that's like oh i was
happy i wasn't going to war like that's
not the kind of guy you would want the
seal teams right i talked to
firefighters and i talked to them and
it's
not that you're necessarily necessarily
wanting there to be fire people's lives
to be at risk but given that there is
one
you want to be the one who responds and
if you're not
around people that feel that way
that's that's a problem and i was proud
to be around a group of people that by
and large want to go
respond to that fire
so to speak in the teams yeah and i
think they eventually got to a point
where
like hey if a guy had just gone to iraq
or afghanistan and maybe he'd gone twice
in a row and now they put him in a
platoon where he's not gonna go and it
was a little it did get more fair
as time went on but this was only what
this was 2005. so it was like
you know
it's a tough one yeah i come back from
that deployment in 2006 and then
i did a little bit of an overseas
augmentation in afghanistan and i i did
get to go there got to see some of the
the country some of the area of
operations i came back from that and
then i did what's called a disassociated
tour so you're not in a platoon and
again
in my
of estimation you're either in a platoon
or you're not and if you're one of the
people who's not it's a distinct feeling
there's nothing like being in a platoon
it's one of the best i mean i would do
that job for 20 years well if i could
uh but so i'm a disassociated tour but
supporting platoons at the team
on a deployment that so you did another
deployment another deployment we but at
least you so you've been to afghanistan
and
now you come back you're doing a
disassociated tour of some job where
you're supporting the teams
were you doing some kind of like recon
element type thing generally speaking
yeah intelligence collection and this
kind of thing so
work it was definitely a leadership you
know i'm i'm a
officer in charge right and you're in
charge of operational stuff that's going
to help yeah absolutely where did you
deploy to to iraq okay yeah so that's
also nice yeah and i got to see the area
i
did get to go out on some operations but
again i'm not in the platoon
so
it was it was
it's just
you can chalk it up to experience but
again i i just can't help but think okay
i i don't have
combat experience and
you know this combat experience is the
mark of respect in the teams now i'm
that deployment goes to 2008 i've been
in five years with a trident
six years into my career and i don't
have combat experience and it's not my
fault
but this is something i felt like
i had been training for and uh i just
felt
insecure about it where were you when
you were in iraq where did you go we
were in the the western provinces there
yeah so near where you were in ramadi
and uh and we had
various i think it was more like an
outstation model at this point did you
at least go like on some obstacles oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah but no shots fired i
mean i don't consider that combat
not that
not that i mean some you know good
operation
there may nope there may not be shots
fired it's just
i didn't have and i wasn't in a
leadership position tactical yeah so
okay so you come back from that
deployment yes so now you're one two
three three deployments deep yep in an
augmentation and
how long was that augmented in
afghanistan two months yeah and i and i
got to do i got to go to an outstation
there and that was that was great but
i've now passed my service requirement i
could get out
you know you have after
uh graduating from the naval academy you
do five years you can punch
like
that would just seem like
so weak
to me you know i honestly i didn't even
think about that right to be honest but
as i look back i'm like wow yeah i could
after that deployment i could have just
gotten out
and then you know things would have been
different
well
it's really hard uh like you like like
we're talking about it's really hard to
look at your career and be like okay i'm
just gonna get out now when you know you
got friends that are fighting you know
that you have more to offer
so you're not getting out no and the one
the one job that i
have to do
is platoon commander if in my opinion if
you don't do that
that's for me where i was in my mind if
i don't do that job i'm failing myself
and everything that i've been through
that's the one
critical
tour that i'm gonna do right
and so you go back to team one to do
that yeah so you get back to team one
now you're a platoon commander correct
and this is now
and i had been
an officer in charge of the previous
element but for me this was a very
special assignment i really
was excited just to be
a platoon leader
in a seal platoon
just felt like
seven eight nine years of
like coming down to this this two-year
assignment and you actually have some
decent experience
for being a platoon commander i mean
you've done multiple deployments
overseas
uh
you you're doing all right this isn't
like a guy that like sometimes you get a
lateral transfer that has like what they
did sometimes they do no deployments
sometimes a lateral transfer is really
senior and they just get put into an oic
position they have no experience
so you've been in the teams the whole
time
and you know you've done multiple
deployments
so you're feeling you must have been
feeling pretty good about being a
platoon commander absolutely and i i
volunteered i would i'm the person who's
going to volunteer i volunteered to go
do the augmentation i didn't need to do
that and that was after a deployment you
know i
pretty quickly after i wanted to go out
i wanted to get the experience
but you go through an 18-month platoon
work-up cycle and and your your
deployment is where your deployment is
and you know you know so six years may
seem like a long time but it's actually
not a lot of
different assignments it's only three
assignments really within that time and
what's going on with your family this
whole time like you've been gone what's
what's happening with the with the
family so at this point it's just my mom
and sister my sister now is
she's in college in kansas my mother
remarried after my father died in 1999
was at the naval academy and
also we how do we we skipped over that
what what happened to your dad when you
were at the naval academy well he was
out on a bike ride one day and was hit
by a car and this just happened
out of the blue i had been
training for the triathlon team and i
think he had kind of taken up
cycling but
it was one of these
mornings that the naval academy was just
getting ready to go to class and
i remember
one of the upperclassmen came by and i
was i'm a sophomore at this point and
it's pretty or i had just been home in
kansas because over the summer
and
he said
the company officer once you wants to
see you
what did i do you know there's probably
i'm sure there was something i had done
in the recent memory that would lead me
to believe like oh man i got caught
so i go in there and he told me the news
and it just was like the floor dropped
out from under me we had a
a the company senior enlisted was a
marine corps gunnery sergeant and he was
he knew he had met my father because at
the end of leap summer
the parents get to come and see
how things were you know you've
graduated please summer and so they
talked about the marine corps
and this gun he was awesome and
he
he was very supportive i got
this happened on a thursday
and
the naval academy in all of its
generosity told me
you can go home on emergency leave
you need to be back
thursday the following week
one week
that still
pisses me off
but i went home
in the funeral and then came back and
was in class a week later
and uh
yeah that's uh
so my mom ended up remarrying i ended up
being overseas when that happened my
sister
is in nursing school in kansas and i'm
single ready to deploy and uh ready to
be a platoon commander in 2008.
so you're you're in your platoon and
going through workup
this is probably when i met you for the
first time
when you're getting your work up you
were training detachment oic yeah we
have good times yeah and i i first of
all
want to thank you for the training
specifically land warfare
you know i didn't get to stay on that
deployment very long but i'm of the firm
opinion that training should be very
difficult
and i think you
really stepped it up and so that
probably saved lives
jason gardner who was
was the
i guess he was the senior enlisted guy
when you guys were out there when you
got hit but he he he talks he's talked
to me about it and like how everything
went down and definitely you know his
whole deployment he has multiple stories
where
you know there was maneuver elements
that they
were able to act on and able to stop and
blue on blues that could have easily
happened that they didn't happen because
they'd been through training that was
really hard so yeah i was definitely uh
my goal was to make the training hard so
that guys were ready for combat um and
you know it was
it was awesome to see it was awesome for
me to be able to watch guys develop and
get really good and
understand what their job was it was a
really steep learning curve but it was
also
like a learning curve that was steep but
also had like really nice steps on it
where you'd you know this training
operation you'd learn this thing and
then they'd figure this other thing out
and then they'd do this other thing we'd
put them in a different scenario and and
then you've got them in mount and
they're learning you know other steps so
by the time guys were getting done they
were
really really competent leaders
and it was awesome to see i remember you
you broke things down in a way that made
sense in its simplicity i remember one
time you were i think i don't know if we
were one-on-one but it was a very close
conversation and you were just saying
listen either you're online or you're in
an l i i just i think it was one-on-one
and it just the way you said it just
really
hit home you know yeah okay and then i
fouled it away and that that was a very
valuable
lesson for me and it's just simple it's
it's pretty simple but sometimes you
know in the chaos you just
you just get overwhelmed and so and then
and then just to prioritize and execute
that's a
really important
rule that
uh you know there could be i i can see
situations in
training environments
or in combat where you're getting
overwhelmed by either too much going on
or you're actually overwhelmed because
there's actually no seemingly viable
course of action i think
those are two different situations but
in the the other the one where there's
just so much going on
okay you know prioritize and execute and
pick the most important thing or either
delegate it or act upon it yourself
with the other situation uh yeah there's
it just doesn't seem like there's any
viable course of action what can we even
do to make this situation better just
realize there's always something you can
do oh you're never out of the fight
even if
you're going to continue doing what
you're currently doing that's an active
choice not a passive choice and there's
a difference there oh yeah there's a big
difference
as you're going through that workup how
was like the relationships with your
with your platoon chief with your lpo
did you guys have a good solid you know
uh platoon from your perspective
yeah we did and and i think
i think that's why our platoon task unit
was selected to go to afghanistan
because i think we did well and
when i say that platoons and tasks don't
get to choose where they deploy but
there is a little bit of a selection
process going on within the team and so
i think i took it as a compliment that
we're going to go on this deployment to
afghanistan and and the west coast teams
had not been deployed to that ao for a
while so
it was it was going to be new and we're
going to be going to iraq this time and
so
we knew that the team the platoons that
we would be replacing we're getting into
it my platoon chief was experienced we
had a prior enlisted assistant officer
in charge was really really great and
you know one of the things i wanted to
approach this position
with in my mind was this leadership
position was
if through the work up i can
ask the opinion of the enlisted members
of the platoon and
really show that i value their advice
that that is going to create a sense of
empowerment and buy-in but also
that their their value is their opinion
is valued in that
can create
an atmosphere of innovation because what
you you don't want to train fire team
leaders to just be responsive to doing
what they're told you want them to have
initiative
and so
in order to do that you know this is hey
what do you think about this what do you
think about this just in the day-to-day
and and i i hope that that you know the
ultimate uh barometer here is is the
opinion of the people in the platoon but
you know and the other the other thing
is
when you're going through a platoon
work-up you're you're trying to train
yourself and you're trying to train
everybody in their various job but you
also have to be training people to be
able to step up and that is one of the
things
going through a training evolution you
have training detachment instructors
evaluating you on your own leadership
and tactical decisions
but you need to
be able to step aside and say okay hey
you got this one let's go it's and it's
it's tough because are people to think
i'm just ducking it out because i don't
want to make a bad call but you do need
to have the ability to do one job above
you and i think
those two things were
what i worked on and i think
especially the second one
you know giving assistant platoon
commander the opportunity to take my
position that that
in hindsight was the right call
for sure yeah and we would
we would do that too you know if we had
a
a platoon commander or a platoon chief
that was really running everything
they'd be the first person we put down
in a training scenario just to let's see
what's gonna happen now
now that we pulled this guy out um
so you
get done with this workup and and now
it's time to go on deployment and like
you said you had been
selected to go to afghanistan
and you end up going
uh on the pdss right the pre-deployment
site survey
yes
you know we didn't go
months in advance so there was
as i recall there was going out a few
months early and then there was going
out three weeks or so before your
platoon
for whatever reason i
we didn't go a few months i don't know
why but
the plan was
for some of the key leaders in the task
unit to go
early three weeks or so early that's
standard procedure i remember thinking
you know this is
this is just is what you do this is a
very
important deployment for me given
and i remember thinking uh
you know if i was only gonna get one if
you can only have one really good
deployment well this is the one i would
choose so it just kind of felt like
things are lining up
yeah and going into that deployment like
i said it was jason gardner and his task
unit uh task unit trident and they had
you know jason describes that as the
most kinetic of his deployments and he'd
done a lot of deployments and so those
guys were
and you know i was tracking those guys i
remember i said uh i would sign my
emails back and forth when they would
tell me what they were doing i would
sign my emails to them uh you know
jocko spiritual advisor to task unit to
try to they got a kick out of that him
and the task unit commander and stuff uh
but you know we were tracking they were
doing a lot of
really kinetic
operations and yeah definitely
for the guys on the west coast getting
ready to go there at that time
that's uh
a good place to be going because
you know
iraq had
settled down a lot at this point you
know kind of after the
the
the uh debt defender group going into
sadder city you know iraq had definitely
settled down
so you guys were going to
the you know the best show in town yeah
and i felt we were ready land warfare in
the desert of california is pretty
similar to the terrain
and the geography of southern
afghanistan and we had a hard
land warfare training block we dialed in
our training specifically over the uh
you know post-workout phase where you
can kind of you know we're going to
deploy and
we're doing a lot of
operations in training that we're going
to mimic
we're mimicking what we felt were
reading in the after action reports we
knew these guys were getting into but we
knew specifically how they were going on
operations so we could tailor the
training for that and we had done all
that so we were we were ready we're
ready to go
so you show up
on the ground how long are you on the
ground for before and when you hit the
ground are they like hey we got one in
the hopper right now we're gonna rock
and roll yeah so some operations are
time sensitive this is one that was not
it was shelved and
i think they wanted to you know in in
rightly so they wanted to
expose us to uh
not only
the execution of the operation but the
planning process the relevant players
sitting on the briefing and all of this
is very valuable who we're gonna talk to
the air crew
and and all of that so yeah they had one
ready for us for the leadership element
that had gone early and keeping in mind
most of the platoon and tasking is still
back in san diego at this point
so as soon as you show up on the ground
are they like all right here's here's
what we got in the books we're gonna how
how
how long was it before you be from the
time you got on the ground do they hand
you like hey come let's give you a brief
a general brief of what's happening
let's let us give you a concept of
operations of what we're about to go do
yeah i think
this is where my memory gets a little
fuzzy i think just given what ended up
happening i i feel like i was on the
ground well certainly no more than 48
hours yep yeah
so you show up
you're getting a brief how many guys
from your task unit are there
it's like three or four i'd say
six to eight six to eight yeah and you
guys all have you get assigned probably
jobs with you know the different
sections or the different squads yes
they have i was assigned to the platoon
leader from one of the two platoons in
country who you know from your task unit
yeah yep
and
so we just go through i i remember
they were
planning but in the final stages and
then i remember sitting on the brief
i remember going to the plywood huts
kidding up
i remember going to the flight line
taking the trucks to the flight line
and are you thinking this time hey look
you have a good understanding of the
operation you know what we're going to
do you're going to get a good feel for
it yeah absolutely and
don't let my
my absence of memory right now the
details of where it happened
affect the impression that i i i just
think given what happened in in i don't
remember
where this happened i don't remember the
i remember the generalities of the
operation of course but i i the details
escaped me
what do you remember
i remember being in canada i remember
going for a run i remember going for a
lift i remember
eating i remember sitting in the
briefing
i remember going to the plywood hut
i remember sleeping one night
i remember
going to the fire pits before we
launched
for
a chaplain-led ceremony a ritual
you know this is this is i think
evident of combat you can it's like you
have bits and pieces of memory facts
and they can get assembled in different
ways and certainly when i talk about the
operation and what happened in order to
get the complete picture you'd have to
talk to other people
my impression
is my own impression and i fully
acknowledge that my memory may be
distorted
but there are absolutely
parts of this that i
completely remember
and
what is interesting to me though is that
some of this
pre-operational
occurrences that they i just don't
really remember a lot of it i don't i
don't know i
i don't know why
do you remember being on the helos going
in yes i'm sitting on the hilo
you know it's it's loud and you're on
night vision goggles no one's really
talking you could hear the pilot chatter
if you want to be on that frequency and
yes it's probably about a 45-minute
flight i mean the general operation was
to conduct a target assault
a compound a drug
a bizarre
i think at this time we were getting
into the
counter narcotics you know this is a
funding source for taliban and this is
in heavily controlled taliban territory
there's bad dudes in this place is it
taliban
controlled village and there's going to
be an assault i'm not in the assault
force element but i'm going to be in the
blocking force and so i'd be shadowing
the element that was pre pre-assault
detached from the main assault force we
would
uh you know after disembarking the
helicopters we foot patrol under a cover
of quiet and darkness middle of the
night
do you remember that
oh yeah okay yeah and and just going
over the plan you know it was just to
secure the top of a hill in the element
that i was right in right and so you're
going to provide kind of like an
overwatch support element yeah
as an assault is going down yeah and all
this is going to happen the assault was
going to happen
either right before or right at first
light
to have a little bit more
visual clarity i think that that's
really what they wanted to do
so you remember the helos coming in
yeah i remember going to the flight line
i remember sitting on the helicopter
remember that getting off the helicopter
you know they're departing you wait for
you know it's quiet again you start foot
patrolling it's kind of uh
you know
offset
so going through i remember walking
everyone's you know night vision goggles
so it's i'm sure the technology has
improved a lot but back then it's green
and black
and i remember you know the
villages there look like they're from
medieval times just with the mud brick
seeing that it's very quiet we're just
moving
and then uh
you know the element that i was a part
of detached from the main assault force
to proceed to the to that hill that
overlooked the target compound we were
gonna
we needed to clear and hold that hilltop
and there was from satellite imagery we
knew there was an
old fort up there from back when the
russians were in afghanistan so
we needed to clear and hold that
structure but it was very crumbled at
this point and
own the high ground and
once we had done that we could set up a
commanding overwatch position with
you know heavy weapons and this kind of
thing
so
foot patrolling we had detached from the
main assault force element foot
patrolling to that hill
it's going to be about a 15 20 minute
hike to get to the top of the hills a
fairly it was not a mountain but it was
a large hill
going single file working their way up
and uh being led we had a navy explosive
ordnance disposable technician up there
and he was sweeping the ground
like you know as standard but
it was recognized that there's a strong
possibility if improvised explosive
devices will have eod up front and have
everybody else covering behind
and as we're working our way up
i remember
i was shadowing with the platoon
commander
and then we kind of had got our way up
to the top
and i just
started moving forward and i've thought
about this a lot i certainly you know
and i'll i'll talk about it later but
you know you can arm chair quarterback
everything and i'm just
detaching from
who i was shadowing because it didn't
seem at this point i'm not being value
added by just standing there and so i
was going to take part
and
moving forward
i
was going step by step
all of a sudden
the next thing i know i'm on the ground
i want to say there was a flash of light
i didn't hear anything i was on the
ground
i didn't know what had happened
now this is where
the experiences of combat can be
different from one person to another and
if i would to get a complete picture
you'd have to talk to everybody that was
up there all i remember is waking up
coming too
i don't know how long i was out i've
talked to people on that operation who
are down below they said
a massive mushroom cloud went off
and that for
a long time nobody was responding on the
radio and that
they thought
perhaps everybody up there was dead
all i remember
is
coming to
i was disoriented
it occurred to me i must have stepped on
a pressure plate i remember that
and pressure plate below the ground the
bomb goes off
i didn't know what the bomb was but it
turns out
i'm told
205 millimeter artillery shells wired
together the second one didn't go off
the first one went off low order so i
mean this can destroy
everybody up there armored vehicle
but the second one didn't explode and
yeah low order
but i'm laying there and
i just remember
thinking i need my teammates
it didn't occur to me
that they were dead but i didn't know if
they were alive i just knew i needed
them
and i remember reaching up for my push
to talk
i remember i got to get man down out
over the radio
and i reached up for where it should be
but it's not there
i was thinking
this is not good and nothing on my kit
my kids is nothing's where it's supposed
to be
only my arm seemed to work i can't see
anything
i think my helmet had been blasted off
night vision gone with it
i can't move
only my arms are working
and i'm laying there
for a second i just felt utterly
helpless because i couldn't do anything
you wanna you want to be doing something
i tried to find my push to talk it's not
there
in my memory the next thing that
happened though my teammates are on me
none of them had been injured bell's
wrong yes
but nobody
incapacitated we could not afford to
have one other person incapacitated up
there
remote position elevated i mean just not
a good situation to even have one person
down but two
really not i mean just if not impossible
to deal with
we had a medic up there of course
navy explosive ordnance disposal is
trying to just protect us at this point
digging for other or sweeping and
digging for other finding additional
ieds i'm told up there there were
several in fact we had been walking on
them none had gone off
until i found one
but the medic fortunately you know
responded wasn't injured responded as he
was trained to do everybody responded as
they were trained to do
selflessly
quickly
to try to save my life and
i remember him putting on a tourniquet
you know we practice putting these on in
training
but you don't ever really
crank it down like you do
when you need to to say actually save
someone's life and to actually cut off
blood flow is staunch blood flow
it's painful
just cranking that thing down
i wasn't in pain from the blast
i was in shock but i do remember
the tourniquet getting cranked down but
that wasn't enough so we applied another
one and then another one
and another one and another one
i'm told it was six total just cranking
each one of them down to try to stop the
blood flow to my lower body
and then i'm told
that there was just this scramble going
on
unbeknownst to me this is happening all
external to my own
inner world right now
but to get the helicopters that
initially dropped us off
which according to the plan we're going
to go back to kandahar airfield a
45-minute flight away
touchdown refuel
unload an army special forces team and
some afghan commando troops bringing
these
soldiers back to be a blocking force for
when that target assault would commence
so
the plan was already to bring the
helicopters back but
this is now a major contingency that has
to be responded to and time and fuel and
everything is going to be of the essence
now i'm only hearing this after the fact
again but
it's going to be a race against the
clock to try to get me out of there
because time is of the essence and so
the guys up above you know they hadn't
cleared the hilltop so there's no way
you can
can
land or hover a helicopter up there i
mean it's just too dangerous so they got
to get me down off this hill that we had
taken
you know it's 20 minutes plus to climb
when we were good
not to mention now dragging someone i
i seem to remember them carrying me
and tripping and falling and i'm falling
from a few feet in the air and it just
in addition to being just damaging to my
body it just was slow they needed to go
to the
the down man drag shoulder straps of my
kit
dragging me and so this is where
their their grit comes into play and
their fitness and their desire to save
my life and why i'm eternally grateful
to my teammates because
they were having to drag me down a steep
dark rocky hilltop
switching off dragging
and it's fatiguing to do that maybe one
or two are going at a time and they're
rotating out the medic is attending to
me and i remember that just i was
probably in and out of
consciousness but i don't recall that i
just recall this just happening in in
real time and with no interruptions this
and people have asked did you think
you're gonna die or anything
no i didn't i just didn't there was no
space in my mind
no
capacity
to think those thoughts because i was
consumed
inundated by the pain
getting dragged over it was sharp craggy
rocks and this i talk about the pain of
six tourniquets getting applied or
any
physical pain of like doing a marathon
or running
a hell week race with a log or something
it's just it doesn't compare to this was
excruciating
and
it was all i could do just to try to
stay awake
and stay awake and stay awake and stay
awake
and i think that was
my desire to live
that
if i could stay awake that that is my
struggle
to live and to not succumb and so that
was what i was focused on and
whether my brain was saying that or not
that's what was happening i wasn't
thinking thoughts of you need to stay
awake in order to live it just was stay
awake
and i think at this point it's getting
very close to the helicopters
and their fuel time fuel calculation
bingo fuel all this you know there if
they hit bingo fuel they're gone
with or without me
and
i'm told that i got loaded onto the
helicopter
really really close to the bingo fuel
mark so i mean
there was a lot that had to line up for
that to happen and for me to get on that
helicopter i shook nick's hand i
remember that i
absolutely remember that he got off the
back
they we're going to continue with the
operation the tail ramp goes up and then
i remember there was a light in my face
and then
it was out
i don't remember anything after that
yeah the um you know
working with jason now um he's talked me
through this this scenario uh a bunch of
times that being said i don't want to
try and you know give his whole side of
the story um
but i mean just a couple key points if
you think uh you know a femoral bleed
can kill you in a minute and a half two
minutes and you had two of them wide
open and the guys were able to get in
there and put enough tourniquets on to
stop that and keep you alive like that
right there the the how quickly they
must have been done that is
just a testament to the training and
their determination to keep you alive i
know that there was
uh jason talks about one of the seals
that got on his hands and knees with the
eod guy with their bayonets to start
probing for ieds because they realized
that the ieds that were up there weren't
magnetic so the the sweeper wasn't
finding them so these two guys are on
their hands and knees probing for a path
to get you guys out of there and then
you know the oic
is getting all this stuff coordinated um
and yet jason usually when he talks
about this he'll mention the fact that
and actually leif and i wrote about this
same oic when he was lace aoic
like calls me calls me on the radio in a
situation and he's like hey this is what
we've got right now we got down guys we
got a iraqi killed like he's talking in
a calm cool collected voice and that's
exactly what jason said
this massive explosion happened
and jason gives him a second then
finally he wants to know what's going on
he says hey what was that
and that oic
calm colon collected said uh we've got a
that was a big that was an ied we've got
a badly wounded guy we're working
through it at this time and then like
jason just let him work
but um yeah the
all the things that fell into place
um from your own mentality to like stay
awake to the medics and other guys
getting tourniquets on to guys on their
hands and knees
with literally with their bayonets to to
try and find a way out of there and then
the guys buddy carrying you and dragging
you down i mean it's uh
it's it's a miracle that you're sitting
here um and the wounds were
horrific uh you know it wasn't
it didn't stop at your legs right this
blast like tore into your guts and
everything else and
uh just
just absolutely horrendous and that's
why you know some of the initial reports
that we got back on the strand was
you know is he gonna make it i don't
know
and like i said in the beginning
when you hear a team guy say i don't
know that's a that's a bad sign
um
so yeah the the platoons
and the task unit they really
did what they were supposed to do they
did what they were trained to do they
did what they planned to do you know and
it's a testament to our training and the
determination of our guys and how much
they care about each other and what
they'll do to to try and you know save
their save their friends
yeah
for any of them listening i i really
just appreciate it it's all i don't even
know what to say
but uh it it
you know when you you think when i hear
this when i anytime i hear an
external account such as what you're
talking about jason
saying
happened it's just
it's just a reminder to me how lucky i
mean to be alive and
i'll take life
like
this missing two legs any day over
dying up on that hill any day so
the pilots as well
thank you
doctors medical professionals i mean
every step along the way
people responded professionally bravely
i remember before deployment we're
reading the after action reports and the
task unit in country at the time which
we were going to be replacing were doing
the turnover off with they had in a
situation where an afghan soldier
stepped on
an ied as well
two legs gone and
as
bad as it may sound to say that that was
practice
and
practice in real life saving in the
field and
i'm told that person later died of
infection they were able to keep him
alive in the field later died of
infection in an afghan hospital
because infection is a serious risk and
that is another thing that i'm very
thankful for getting dragged down that
hill
to not i mean through
ages and ages worth of goat
and dust
to not have massive infections
is a miracle
and uh
yeah i i for many many reasons i'm very
very grateful for the fact that i'm here
and that i have what i have
when did you
wake up
i woke up
about
10 days later give or take a day
and i'm in what appears to be a hospital
room
with
my mother's face about two feet away
and
i can tell you
when you go to bed at night and you wake
up in the morning you
have a general sense of the
progression of time
relative to say taking a nap this
afternoon when you wake up
when you are in a medically induced coma
for about 10 days
you wake up and you don't have any sense
of time progressing
my last memories were being dragged of a
helicopter into a helicopter at night
being on foot patrol being the top of
this mountain you know now i wake up and
i'm just all of a sudden in a hospital
with my mom's face right there i had no
how the hell did i get here what the
hell happened is what i'm thinking what
the hell happened
and so could you talk immediately did
you look at your mom
what was that what was that awakening
like
the really one of the first things i
said to her she had been
summoned from the basement of
the
hospital bethesda naval hospital my
mother and sister had been told what had
happened in in those 10 days had come to
d.c so they were there my sister was up
above near the icu she calls down to our
mom
drinking coffee so she comes up and gets
up in the gown i just remember seeing
her right there
and pretty quickly
i commented on the coffee breath it was
hitting me
i'm not a coffee drinker and her
she was so close to me the coffee breath
was just blasting me
i'm not a fan of coffee breath either
but i remember
no one was saying anything specific and
uh
my mind was off i was on some heavy
painkillers and my lower body was
covered in blankets i just i wasn't
looking down that way maybe i knew but
no one had said anything and i didn't
know for a fact
and i
do remember asking a medical
professional to the right of my bed
whether my
are my legs gone and that i remember
that person replying just yes
and that's
that's tough to hear
it's tough to hear out of the blue it's
really tough to process and just think
about
you know you do have no idea at that
point or did you you said you had like a
suspicion
i feel like i i feel like
when i was in the medically induced coma
that
maybe people's conversations around me
were sinking in but i i didn't know for
a fact and and to be then told
in a state you know i'm not completely
lucid at this point but like i can
comprehend what that means and what that
means for the future
and that that is
not the entirety of what's going on
your legs are amputated above the knees
your pelvis is shattered you have an
external fixator contraption sticking
out of you don't know how long that's
going to be in
you have a couple bags attached to you
one of which is a colostomy bag
and i didn't know what that was but once
someone explained it to me
i'm thinking okay that's something
people don't want to have normally
a bladder two coming out of my bladder
my
fingers are in
casts
and
i had a burning fever
and this i had a ng tube up my nose down
my throat into my stomach i was going
through surgery monday wednesday friday
there was one week i remember monday
wednesday thursday friday surgery and
these are surgeries that are at a
minimum seven hours
sometimes 10 12 there's 14 hours
surgeries
i mean i was clocking
20 30 something hours a week of surgery
time easy week after week after week and
so my intestines weren't working and
actually with all that i had going on
this ng tube up my nose down my throat
to try to decompress my stomach because
the intestines weren't working was the
bane of my existence because it was i
wasn't allowed to eat or drink anything
because my stomach wasn't functioning so
i was fed and hydrated by iv
so you can imagine how dry your throat
gets you cannot drink a single sip of
water
i was allowed to take some ice chips but
in order to talk to anybody i had to
chew gum to generate the saliva to do so
and i had a lot of people coming in the
room wanting to talk i mean on the day
that i woke up i'm told there were over
70 people in the visiting room creating
a stressful environment for my mother
i wanted to rip that energy tube out
but i knew they'd put the thing back in
and i'd be awake when they put it in
and i was awake at one point when they
did put it in not because i ripped it
out but
it is not fun to have that thing
inserted
and then yeah this fever this
inexplicable fever we thought it was
infection but it was an infection but i
just had this burning fever but the
worst part about that was that this
fever
combined with
a bad mental reaction that i was having
to the painkillers i wasn't on
the right kind of painkiller that worked
with my
mind and so
you can imagine a bad fever a bad
reaction to the painkillers
nightmares delirium all centered around
afghanistan my last
memories i remember one and these are
these are as real as i'm talking to you
right now these nightmares delirium i
mean just
it was i'm in this just like we're
talking right now there's no ability to
look from an outside perspective and say
okay this isn't real you're going to get
through this you're going to wake up
you're in it my platoon calling me
a coward for being
not on the deployment with them and this
kind of thing being on a foot patrol
getting dismembered by some kind of rack
machine i mean just just awful stuff and
so
this is really
the ground zero low point for me
waking up in an icu room finding out
this is going on and then
and then just struggling how long is
this sort of bottom time last for
i was in the icu for three weeks
right off the bat i ended up
going back there again but three weeks
not eating not drinking ng tube and week
after week of surgery so it was a good
20 plus days of just
really just hell i mean the there was a
service member in the room i see room
next to me was a helicopter probably
been shot through the head i heard about
him managed to land the helicopter and
at one point he died
while i was in the icu
only two visitors could come at a time
you're hooked up to every contraption on
earth
monitoring your body your
your body signals
they can't ever make the room dark
you're close to the nurse's station you
can't sleep
every hour they're checking you
so i wasn't sleeping i remember
if you took away
surgery time that it was an astonishing
long time that i had last slept
and then when i could fall asleep it
would just be the it would be delirium
nightmares and one point
my sister tells me that at about five or
six in the morning a icu nurse who sees
a lot i mean this is a
combat
icu room in a hospital uh
calls her crying saying that you're you
need to get in here and talk try to help
your brother he's just
breaking down i i don't
i don't know which one of those
nightmares that i've described this was
but there was there was just like a a
total bottom point i was on dilaudid
which is a very powerful opiate they did
shift me over to morphine and that was
that was much better for
[Music]
not just pain management but also for my
psyche and everything
then do you
do you uh start like making a turning
point and they wrap up some of the
surgeries and is it like a slow crawl
out of the
pit
it is
in addition to dealing with
some of the
factors of disconnection from the
platoon and that was also going through
my mind there was
there was progress and then there'd be
setbacks they'd say it's okay it's three
steps four or two steps back you're just
gonna have to get used to this well if
there's three steps forward they're
probably like
33 steps back in the beginning because
it's just it seemed like that there
would be setbacks you know i alluded to
the fact that i couldn't eat or drink
for a few weeks at one point i'm gonna
do the swallow test this is a big a big
step here if you if i can eat some
chocolate pudding and swallow it okay
i've passed and then i can maybe
actually take some food and not have to
be fed by iv
so i took the chocolate pudding and i
mean it tasted really good i hadn't had
any food in weeks and i remember just a
couple minutes later it all just comes
back out fail so back on the ng tube you
know ivy
i had a routine surgery on my hand my
right hand
was damaged and there needed to be a
plate put in
i had a tendon that was damaged and so a
very routine surgery and i'm i was
actually out of the icu at this point
i wake up from the surgery and i'm back
in the icu
what happened why am i here again
and i got the admiral of the hospital on
down coming through apologizing
something bad happened in this surgery
what was it well
i apparently had a normal amount of
potassium in my system in the resident
anesthesiologists these are training
hospitals so they're always training new
military doctors the resident
anesthesiologist
either messed up or just didn't take
note of the amount of potassium in my
system and gave
administered a anesthetic that releases
potassium so my system in the middle of
this very routine surgery flooded with
potassium
and my heart stopped i
i'm told
by the
surgeon who responded brilliantly
that she had to put the chest pedals on
me and and shock me back and shock my
heart back into function and so i wake
up from
i
basically died and had to be
resuscitated in a routine surgery after
going through all of this weeks later
it's i mean to me that's unacceptable
but
this you know
you may think you're over the hill but
you're not
anytime you go into surgery it's a it's
a risk
like it seems hard to and like a lot of
things had to fall the line to get you
to survive coming off the battlefield
but it's like just the beginning
just the beginning i mean you know i'm
in addition to realizing all the medical
complications that i have
you're thinking
what is my life going to look like
how how am i going to do basic things am
i going to be in a wheelchair am i even
going to get out of this hospital am i
going to get through surgery
will i get to walk again how am i going
to shower
can i drive a car
dating girls what's that going to be
like
how
this was my first combat deployment this
was the first operation within the
deployment my platoon wasn't even on the
ground yet and so
it just felt like
you know
why me i would tell myself well okay
let's just say if someone had up on that
hill had to step like you should want it
to be you you should
say i'm the one who can handle this
i survived i can make a good life
do i really feel that
am i just saying that
i want to believe that it should have
been me if it had to happen to someone
do i really believe that
how you know this job felt like my
calling is every hey the only thing i
ever wanted to do really in my career
and it just seemed like it was gone my
identity was very much wrapped up in
being a team guy yeah okay you can still
stay in the teams but guess what
i had a senior ranking officer come at
one point and visit and i was trying to
do physical therapy and really was
focused on my physical therapy not
talking to this individual so much
certainly not talking about career plans
and was kind of saying well you know you
can stay in the teams we can send you to
acquisition school
and i'm just
like this
that's just not you know i
so okay you're not gonna do this job the
way in which you've been doing it even
if you can stay in the community
but as i said you're either in a platoon
or out of platoon and i'm going to be
out of a platoon people say yeah but you
know as an officer you progress through
you're going to be
even if this didn't happen you'd be
you know you'd be administrating you'd
be doing some staff tours and yeah okay
this happened on the first
operation within the deployment it's you
don't get it it's just it's not the same
and but most importantly it was just i'm
not going to be on this deployment with
my teammates if this had to have
happened to me
let it happen at the very end of the
deployment it was what i was thinking
but to be
disconnected like that is uh is tough
it's and so
in addition to a physical component i
think there was absolutely a mental
challenge that i was also dealing with
what was the first
like what was the first positive step or
the positive light that you saw
i remember one day
and this is very basic
but they were saying okay we're going to
work on getting you up out of bed i had
this shattered pelvis it was
surgically fixed with two screws i had
this external fixator
that is a contraption
the stayed in place for about 100 days
they took it out surgically at one point
but that meant that i couldn't get an
external fixator on your pelvis drilled
drilled into them over a hundred days
yeah drilled into the it's two crossbars
extending out you can't i happen to be a
stomach and side sleeper and you know in
addition to everything else going part
of the reason with the sleep maybe
it's just that i couldn't turn so i'm
stuck on my back
and you
when this thing gets taken out
surgically
they're okay you're ready to get we need
to get you out of your back off of the
bed because you're developing bed sores
and this kind of thing
but it's not going to be easy to balance
like why sitting up that's not a big
deal
i set up like two one person on either
side of me set me up out of the hospital
bed and they let go and it was just like
fall back
because your abs were or you just didn't
know how to do it
the system of balance and the flu i
don't know if we have fluids that kind
of dictate our balance that just was
gone after being bedridden for
100 days
i mean definitely i had atrophied and
strength but i think just the whole
system of balance was out so this is
still not like i'm asking for that
but but but after a few efforts
i was able to hold it and it was like it
was like doing like a plank or something
you know where you're just you're
shaking and you're folding you're
concentrating but i was able to hold it
for a little bit of time and i felt okay
i'm out of bed okay that's awesome at
some point this means i'm going to be
able to transfer into a wheelchair now
and then when i get in this wheelchair
i'm going to be doing laps around this
hospital i'm going to do as much as so
you were fired up immediately to get out
to get
to get outside i mean that that was
actually one of the other challenges
when i became an inpatient it just
didn't make sense to me
why can't i just get into a courtyard
just to get outside if it's a sunny day
like that would be awesome
i love being outside i'm an outdoor is
there a reason for it is it infections
what is it well i
the cynical interpretation is that
when you're in an icu forget about it
but when you're in the inpatient status
there's a nurse who's balancing now
four patients total i see you it's one
on one
you have
undevoted attention from your nurse but
now you're getting
juggled with a few other patients and so
i had a lot of i still had some
apparatus attached to the bed and all of
that would it would take a team of
people
not to mention the on on duty nurse who
then
might not be able to attend with other
patients so there was a logistic aspect
to this that i think was challenging
at the end of the day you know i felt
this means so much to me can't you just
do that i just want to get out i just
want to get outside
and
there was one they're going to make it
happen finally and this was after a
while i think longer than it should have
been but you know i i don't want to be
too
um reprimanding of them
they got out of the courtyard it was a
sunny day it was kind of like the sun
had come through and it just uh
was a very powerful moment for me just
to be outside my mom and sister were
with me and
okay i got outside that's that's a step
eventually get into the wheelchair
and eventually i was able to start doing
laps around the hospital pushing myself
i don't want people to push me but to be
able to just cover ground on my own
is i think a basic
human
need
that
needs to be fulfilled and when
you're getting pushed in a wheelchair or
on a bed by someone else it's not the
same thing
so it's about me getting a wheelchair
and be able to move
so then when when did you start making
what was the next big step that you took
like you're now in a wheelchair you're
able to get yourself around
yeah i think the next step was there's
gonna be a day pass coming up okay a day
pass means not the whole day but a
couple hours i'm gonna get to go
out of this hospital
with my mother and sister out to dinner
i'll be in a wheelchair
and
it'll be about two hours and you can
come back
so i'm in anticipation of this
laying there in bed and thinking
wow i'm gonna leave this hospital
a second and be like
that's awesome oh wait
people are gonna look at me
i don't look right i don't look normal
i look different
i'm used to being anonymous
nothing you know don't stand out really
it's an average guy
now i look different radically different
what are people going to stare at me
what's what's this going to be like
and
i was just thinking you know
i'm going to have to get used to this is
my future reality whether i'm in a
wheelchair or whether i'm on prosthetic
legs
you look different
and if you do not get used to this
somehow and eventually you're going to
be bitter for the rest of your life
so i started thinking
along these lines of you know body image
and stuff
whenever i get these prosthetics and i
don't have them yet whenever that is i
don't know when it's going to be
i'm going to boost them up a little bit
so i'm a little taller
i was five nine and i was thinking six
foot would be pretty good if people are
going to look at me i might as well be
taller
but i remember getting on that day pass
you know i'm sure how long had it been
from like from you showed up there until
now you're getting your first day pass i
i would say two solid months
two months which in the grant you know
at the time it seemed like a long time
in the grand scheme of things
things were moving fairly rapidly
i
had the bag still
i'm
about to be discharged from bethesda
about to be an outpatient first i got to
go to walter reed that's where i'm going
to do the physical therapy i got to be
an inpatient there for a few days just
to get in their system
did the day pass
my mother and sister were being taken
care of by special operations command
they had a program
to
provide housing apartment out in town
for
the family of service members and also
for the service members for me whenever
i am allowed to be out of this hospital
this is a privilege you know really a
luxury that
army
and marine corps soldiers non-socom
didn't have
it's you know at the time i didn't know
any of this but yeah this was very
fortunate that my mother and sister had
an apartment out on town that apartment
that i would be able to go to so the
next thing and this this is just to get
get that that discharge to become an
outpatient and then after that it's
you're starting physical therapy you're
gonna learn how to walk again okay roger
that
so now you started learning to walk yeah
and this and you're an outpatient so now
you're living out in town living with my
sister our mother had gone back to
kansas to resume work and you know she
felt like things were in a good place
but she had been like
not like
allowed to go to the east coast covered
long as you need but you know i'm living
with my sister my sister was a nurse in
new york city quit her job to come down
and take care of me
and when i was an inpatient
other people were taking care of me but
there absolutely was was a phase where i
was ready to be out of the hospital but
i was no means ready to take care of
myself and live out in town no way
and i'm a single guy and so the fact
that my sister did that is just so
so awesome and
she would drive me to the hospital every
day for my physical therapy and it's now
it's okay you're gonna get fitted for
prosthetics you're gonna do physical
therapy every day okay that's working
out i'm gonna be working out every day
and this is a new sport it's kind of how
i thought about it you're gonna learn
how to walk on these prosthetics first
you're gonna have short ones they don't
bend then you're going to have bending
ones because i don't have knees so the
prosthetics are going to be my knee
joint and it's going to be tough but
it's you got as much time as you need
and
every monday through friday every day
you get two hours of physical therapy
and then i have a lot of other
appointments with the various
departments that i fell under plastic
surgery orthopedic surgery
etc so that that was it was just
hospital days
end up being in the hospital four to six
hours about every day as an outpatient
coming in
driving there with my sister coming back
at the end of the day
and then how long was it before you were
up on your kind of like
normal full-size prosthetics yeah i'd
say that was so my my goal was okay my
platoon is coming back in march
if i could be on the knee prosthetics
the ones that ben even if i have
crutches or canes
that's okay but just to be there on the
flight like not in a wheelchair i if i
can get up on the prosthetic so first
you have to go through the short legs
that was late january i want to say all
of february i started
eventually learning how to walk on the
knees and because they bend under you
it's really difficult and
keeping in mind that i'd atrophied a lot
you need a lot of hip strength and core
strength
even now this
walking a long distance because they're
heavy it's fatiguing so you can imagine
when you're really really at this low
point is very difficult i would just be
so tired at the end of the day
i had i remember thinking at the time
you got two hours of physical therapy
that's what's automatically provided the
physical therapists are working with
other service members
and they don't have time to be with you
for four hours or five hours but i was
thinking okay
if i do twice the amount of physical
therapy per day
i'll get out of here in half the time
but the math doesn't work like that
but i also got to say when i got to
walter reed
physical therapy i was surrounded by
dozens of injured service members
and
some of these people were missing three
limbs four limbs
four limbs three limbs
i remember one day
looking at the therapy mat next to me
it's pretty
pretty easy to look around and you can
see
a quadruple amputee or in this case a
triple amputee i don't know what was
going on in his head but he was working
hard
right right then and there to make his
life better
and so once i got in that environment
it becomes competitive
and it also provides a sense of
perspective
i'm not saying
that perspective just let me okay i feel
better about myself because others have
it worse
but it did
allow me to
really highlight the unique
circumstances the conditions
that i should be thankful for just
realize okay i've got arms that work
i've got a brain that works i can see i
can hear i can
talk
i'm not badly burnt i'm not blinded
i'm alive
and we know people who
are not here that i mean their families
would give anything for them to be in
this situation
just be missing two legs but to be alive
i know that
and so
i'm going be thankful for what i have
not focus on what i'm missing that
that is really what that environment
taught me
at what point did you start saying to
yourself you're gonna start doing you
know like wild again well you know
i i really liked i was really like
hiking and running trail running just
getting on the woods i
i actually did a couple
extreme hike actually in hindsight
stupid hiking excursions like either
before or after a deployment
because that's when you get the most
amount of time
these like pre-or post-deployment leave
excursions but my point was i i just
like being outside and i like being
active and so i was definitely thinking
i want to run and that's a good a good
goal to have because in order to run you
need to be able to walk
so that kept me motivated and
and
i started i got a hand cycle and i'm in
dc right in the hand cycle
it's not a not a great one but i at
least was able to start getting outside
and just do it by myself on a bike show
near the apartment where my sister and i
were living
and were you were you able to meet the
platoon when they came home yeah yeah so
what was that like
so
the
generosity of
someone affiliated with the hotel del
coronado put a room
up for my sister and i to go out to san
diego coronado stay at the hotel del
ocean front well i got the ocean front
room she had the other one that didn't
face the ocean but uh
uh and then the
their the platoon
redeployment bird kept getting delayed
so like this it was supposed to be like
a couple days it ended up being like a
two-week stay at the hotel dell waiting
and i was at north island on the flight
line when they got off i think i may
have had one cane
but that was that was
for me at least a very proud moment to
just be at least be standing and i don't
know if any of them knew when they got
off the bird that i was going to be
there i don't know what they were told
but uh you know i shook everybody's hand
and then
and then the festivities commenced
yeah
so back to the hand cycle you're
starting to think about being able to do
that you're starting to push yourself
um
what was it like
didn't you end up doing the new york
city marathon at some point oh i did i
did this was on a hand cycle and part of
it was like hand cycle and then
run the last stretch i think i hand
cycled 16 miles ran 10 and
just getting out there like that and
getting a sense of my athleticism
regaining a sense of my physicality was
huge
to
realize that i can still be an athlete
that there's this whole world of
adaptive sports just about anything that
you want to do or had done
you can do maybe in a different maybe
it's going to take your upper body to do
it or maybe you're going to be doing it
in prosthetics but that
you can be an athlete and then i
had heard about
this
thing called the paralympics and then
that was very
very intriguing to me as well what did
you heard about it
well i heard it's basically the olympics
for people with physical disabilities
and it's not the special olympics it's
different it's under the us olympic and
paralympic committee it is
it's competitive it's difficult
you'll get world-class coaching
you can
represent the country overseas it is a
direct representation of the united
states overseas and you can be part of a
team there's all these different sports
out there there's summer there's winter
it's just like the olympics
did you have any inkling of what you'd
be trying to do in there
i was thinking something along the lines
of running or cycling i actually there
was a recruiter a liaison at walter reed
the clear place to find
athletes for the paralympic program was
walter reed you got a young
motivated
soldiers marines troops that are looking
to get uh
you know looking to get after it yeah
yeah you know and so they had robert
jones in there right yeah yeah i was
injured before rob and rob maybe a year
before or something like that something
like that yeah so this is just you know
this this environment fed off each other
you know rob
was just so fired up to get back after
it and and there's
some people
not
maybe maybe being an athlete wasn't
their thing
some people
want to get into a career some people
were struggling
some like rob were just
just
doing all sorts of impressive stuff and
and i think
you know you hear you hear about someone
before you
oh that person was a double amputee
above the knee they did this and that
and oh wow this is possible and then and
then it create there's a competitive
environment
rob he was a little bit after saw me
running and and then he's like you know
i'm gonna run but i'm gonna run faster
than dan you know this kind of thing and
so it was it just was a good environment
it makes me think if i had gone through
this in a vacuum in a bubble
would the outcome have been the same
perhaps
i think
it helped though to have that sense of
perspective and to see what other people
are dealing with
and
and in some cases really struggling with
but
military medicine can keep people alive
these days in ways just not possible and
so
you're seeing i mean it was
not uncommon to see triple amputees
quadruple amputees
and
i think there was a bond in that
environment that transcended
your service your rank
what you did in your service
that
is
different than the bond i had in the
teams but it is it was very special
so the recruiters come from the
paralympics and they come scoping out at
walter reed looking for some motivated
troops who want to get some and one of
these guys introduce himself to you or
something
one of the yeah one of the recruiters uh
she asked do i want to go to san diego
for a sports camp yeah that sounds
awesome trip to san diego and i go out
there
not really expecting anything but really
it's a trip to san diego i'll get to do
some adaptive sports sounds good and the
coach two coaches from the paralympic
nordic ski team that's cross-country
skiing and biathlon approached me and
hey you ever thought about doing
biathlon
i thought that was running and swimming
but it's cross-country skiing with
target shooting
that sounds pretty cool
well hey you know they had like a indoor
ski erg
there and like a little laser shooting
station okay this isn't on snow but do
you want to come to snow in a few months
it's august right now november
late november
west yellowstone montana camp
okay i'm there now i still had a
colostomy bag i wasn't done with surgery
the one major surgery i still had
remaining was to take away the colostomy
bag
and
this sounds awesome i go out to west
yellowstone i don't know how to dress as
an amputee with my stumps i don't know
how to
i don't know the clothing i don't have
all that i'm in this thing called a sit
ski which now i mean now at a higher
level it's all carbon fiber it's custom
fit to me it's lightweight strong but
back then it was like a lawn chair on
two skis and it was not
not an athletic device
but and then okay cross-country skiing
all you got is two pulls you got to use
your your upper body your arms your core
your back
and you don't get to use your lower body
you're strapped into this thing how are
you going to stop how are you going to
turn
okay figuring this out my future
teammates are just
racing by me it's like wow they're fast
i don't know if i could ever get to that
level but at a minimum just being
outside west yellowstone montana is one
of my favorite places to cross country
ski it's near big sky it's
just pine trees you're in this you feel
like you're in the woods yeah the trails
are machine groomed but once you're out
it's quiet there was days we were just
getting it was a good snow this is late
november it's not always consistent but
that year
fortunate for me because if it would
have been a dry year and canceled who
knows
but it was dumping snow which isn't
always good for cross-country skiing
when you're trying to power through with
your poles but
more than anything i just
had this connection with nature that was
so important i had been running on the
prosthetics i wasn't trail running i
wasn't
running you know out in the woods i was
hand cycling a little bit in dc the cars
honk at you it's not a feeling of nature
so this was this was just different and
i really
just wanted to keep doing it and so well
then what what happens what's the course
because is that that ends up being what
your first competitive sport is is that
right it's all i've done in the
paralympics and i
for me it started because i just wanted
to be in the woods and then it was like
okay you could actually start doing this
full
full-time training and get better and
just see where you can go maybe you'll
make a paralympic team get to go to the
paralympic winter games i'm still on
active duty i'm still in the hospital i
still have this surgery i got through
the surgery big recovery they cut open
my core again to take to reconnect
my intestinal system
i saw i still have orders at walter reed
i got to get out of the navy
i had a conversation with the head seal
admiral he was like well we'll support
you if you want to do this
three years training train for the sochi
paralympics
assign you to
fort carson colorado 10 special forces
group i'll be training up in winter park
i had met a coach up there in winter
park and they
have they got snow they got a training
area so i took i took orders i mean that
again i'm very grateful to the nsw
community for doing that
it
for me i i just
i could have gotten out but there was
something special about still being in
and still training for this sport to go
represent the country
and so
the way i saw it i have orders to move
out to colorado and to train i'm gonna
train and train and train
and probably train a little bit too much
and maybe over trained
in that
desire to kind of work through my injury
and to show that i've
overcome it
and so that was for the for the sochi so
how did that end up going yeah i i
showed up there a newer athlete i've
been doing the sport for three years
living and training in colorado and
now that i look back on that time
i'm just wondering why
did someone who lost their legs and
within two years move out to colorado
didn't know anybody i knew that local
coach let's just go train in a sport
that like 98 of my training was by
myself
hours
in the off-season cross-country skiers
roller ski i had this mountain board
apparatus so i'm on the dirt roads out
there
and and just
training and training and training and
probably working through some things but
it just felt good to be an athlete i
could train for this sport
be part of a team follow a training plan
see progress
set long-term goals
work towards those long-term goals put
the skill put the skills and the
training of the test overseas
represent the united states if i can
make a paralympic team
this seemed like a logical thing to do
for me coming out of
my time in the teams and in the service
so but i'm still in the service and i'm
representing you know the navy and all
that i put a little bit of pressure on
myself i showed up at the i did make the
team for sochi
and
we know now in retrospect that russians
were doing
uh performance-enhancing drugs that's
not necessarily verifiable but i mean i
think plenty of people have come out and
said that that was happening and maybe
don't have the sample but there was
there was a very
tough competition cross-country skiing
is a tough sport
the distances range from 15 18 kilometer
races down to sprints but how what do
you did you do
i i did six races at the sochi games and
that's that's pretty standard so the
longest so it would have been six races
in cross country three 15 kilometer
10 kilometer
and then 800 meters sprint and then in
biathlon 15 kilometer
12.5 kilometer 7.5 kilometer these six
races happen in like eight days it's
it's intense you don't get a lot of
recovery
and i was kind of in the the 10th 12th
place area 14th
the fields aren't as deep as in the
olympics but they're still very
competitive and i made the sprint final
that one and got six plays in the six
out of six on the sprint final but made
it to the final i exited sochi
to be honest a little bit disappointed
because i think i put too much pressure
on myself
and you think you over trained too i
think so i was living at very high
altitude in winter park colorado fraser
colorado living at 8 700 feet it's
altitude has pros and cons a lot of
people think it's a
it's just a win-win you're up at high
altitude training for an endurance sport
but you do develop the red blood cells
that
improved efficiency in your
your transportation system internally
but you
cannot train to the extent that you can
at sea level and so your neuromuscular
system is not
performing at the
so what's it best to do both
yeah like the mile to do down yeah the
model is live high train low if
you have unlimited funds you would be at
sea level
or in this case where there's snow but
lower altitude and you would lit you
would pressurize your house to be at
like ten thousand fish assuming
you can recover you step out the door
yeah
yeah and then when you you know and you
spend a lot of time in your house and
you go out and then now you're you're at
sea level so it just you have the red
blood cells from the altitude inside and
then now you're training fast and hard
at a higher tempo a higher intensity
than you can at altitude so you you make
it to the olympics you come in 6th 12th
10th whatever and you're all kind of
pissed at yourself because
well i think you know as i look back i
mean what was i expecting it was nude i
mean you want to just be
given this yeah and like it's like
there's not as much reward if it was
easy but
the other thing is i think i put too
much focus on the end result
that
there's actually a different focus the
focus should just be on
the process
training
execution of the training plan modifying
as necessary making adjustments at the
end of every season based on what went
well and what could have gone better
and that if i can
make some changes to equipment
make some changes where i'm living i
moved to new england
and so i'd be at a lower altitude
and that
if i can execute the process of of
training and preparation that
and then of course on race day
go
dig deep and go as hard as i can in a
smart way that at that point
you got to be happy with what happens at
that point so i i ended up
training for the next cycle and these
are four-year cycles and you move to new
england go to school right yeah i to use
my gi bill and
i i just i had some friends from the
teams who had gone to the kennedy school
of government and wanted to go there it
was a one-year program i was very much
still training a little
skeptical of whether i could get in that
the training hours that i needed i
didn't know how demanding the academic
program was going to be but i found that
with discipline and time management go
to bed early wake up at my training zone
7am to 9am go to class at 10 rest of the
day and then recover and i often in
colorado prior to in the train up for
the 2014 games
through boredom and through just a
desire to to be training and thinking
you know this is like a buds more is
better yeah more is better if you train
twice as hard you're going to get twice
as fast it doesn't it doesn't really
work that way and you don't yeah
there's days you training has to be hard
yeah but then you have to give
you obviously know that well i'm
actually obviously may not know this i'm
like the worst
yeah echo is in full support of like
heavy rest
[Laughter]
make sure you're recovered yeah yeah so
you're training so when you when you're
going to school you're training
basically two hours a day
yeah and whereas in colorado i've been
training like three to four at high
altitude not giving myself the recovery
and then you start getting dialed in you
got a good coach out there that's
helping you get dialed in on all this
well a physiologist and it was remote
coaching but yeah i mean looking like
uploading workouts getting feedback
and and then in the winter i just i was
exploring okay because the it was 20
the first year i skied i did not ski
with the team the next year i needed to
ski with the team internationally to be
able to qualify for the games in 2018
and i was working out okay like i can
train up in vermont there's a really
good
center at craftsbury vermont from nordic
skiing and there's a coach who will help
me with biathlon i can drive there if i
take you know compressed classes to be
like tuesday wednesday thursday i can
drive up there thursday afternoon train
friday saturday sunday monday
and then there's a ski track in boston i
can't do biothon there but there's a
what a ski
sorry ski track oh okay yeah
the they make snow from the charles
river
and it's about a
time like 15 minute drive so i can do a
workout there and i'm like i think this
is possible
so i i think i can be a student and
train and how hard was school was were
they pushing you hard
it was difficult if you did all the work
and if you did all the reading and
i mean i don't know many people that can
actually do all the reading i was also
training as a full-time athlete yeah
you got it done is what i've yeah i got
it done and i got good grades i i think
i think they're not in the business of
trying to separate people out so you
know you're there didn't you go to
didn't you go to divinity school as well
so what was that all about i had gone to
the kennedy school and i really liked
being in class and learning from people
and seeing new ideas you don't have to
agree with them but it's i gone to a
military school for college i just
thought this is this is a good
opportunity and
i met some students from the divinity
school and they said it's not it's not
what it sounds like you can go into the
ministry if you're inclined but there's
this other program it's just an academic
study of
religion
or questions that religion is trying to
answer
and so i thought
well i'll apply and i was accepted i
studied ethics there and
i got to take some classes
through electives it was a very a
wonderful program in the sense that it
was broad and i can kind of just take
whatever interested me i took some
classes on buddhism and i'm not a
buddhist
but there was something in my exposure
to that
way of thinking that really resonated in
the athlete
in me
this idea that
you know life is suffering and
i can identify with that even when you
are happy you're suffering because
you know that that happiness is
not permanent
and
that there's a way to
that that this suffering comes
ultimately from our
desire and craving
for for happiness
that there's a way to end this
suffering and that is through a process
but the process can involve mindfulness
and meditation and so i was exposed to
that
and i think when i was in the teams i
would have scoffed at this but
i was thinking now i'm of the point
where
i am trying to get every
tenth of a percent of performance that i
can and if this was the difference
between
getting fourth place and getting third
and i didn't do it well i just at least
want to i tried everything that could
help me be a better human a better
athlete and in biathlon the reality is
you're skiing
hard and you have to come into the range
and you have to place five shots
precisely with other athletes next to
you shooting an announcer saying
something
a crowd
your heart beating maybe numb fingers
from the cold
pressure
knowing you need to hit the shots
that if you can cultivate an ability to
be aware of your mind and be aware
more quickly when your mind has drifted
away
from the task right in front of you that
that could be a competitive advantage
not to mention cultivating this ability
to just focus and to focus on your
breath or to have the ability to through
breathing recenter yourself i think
that this is actually something that i
could have benefited from
highly when i was in the teams
the ability
to be aware of where your mind is
it's almost like you're developing a
outside view of your mind and you can
see when it's gone away and so i started
developing this kind of practice just
through some classes i took and and that
kind of exposure was exactly why i did
the the divinity school program
yeah i've been running into a lot of
that stuff um you know i
uh in the book leadership strategy and
tactics i talk about how my
my very first platoon i was we were
doing uh
gas oil platforms and i basically we
were online no one's making a call and i
kind of stepped back and looked around
and
and made a call
got praised for it you know i was kind
of expecting as a new guy to get told
shut up but
but it was like the initial idea in my
head of taking a step back and detaching
and being in a position mentally where
you're looking around and you're not in
the problem but you're outside the
problem and that was really beneficial
to me
and then you know i've come to find out
uh
like
for instance when you take a step back
and you well when you're when your
field of vision opens up more broadly it
relaxes you that's why when you go to
the ocean and you look at the sunset you
feel relaxed that's why when you stand
on a mountaintop and you look out over
you know vast span of land you feel more
relaxed
those things those are physiological
things that happen because
as a
as a animal if there's a movement in the
jungle like a tiger you need to focus on
that and it amps up your heart rate and
it gets you ready to fight puts
adrenaline in your system
yet the opposite of that is when you
when you open up your field of vision it
becomes it relaxes you so kind of
unintentionally for me as a young seal i
figured out hey if i take a step back
and look around i'm more relaxed it was
more of a byproduct it wasn't i was
doing it to relax and then the other
thing that i figured out was like
any time you'd hear someone panicking on
the radio screaming you're like hey what
are you doing i need people over here or
whatever
and so you'd make fun of that guy we'd
make fun of those people and so i would
always when i was going to key up my
radio i'd take a breath
and it turns out that when you take a
breath that also calms you down so
i kind of stumbled into these things and
other things throughout my career that
now when i either learn about the
physiological
the physiological things that happen in
our body that also people use things
like meditation to drive
these same physiological things i kind
of like got lucky and stumbled upon them
and
just
you know now i'm sort of starting to put
two and two together now as i get older
and learn more about the world
you know these physiological things that
i sort of stumbled upon people go out
and seek
and figure out and you know same thing
with like jiu jitsu if you lose your
temperature in jiu jitsu you're going to
lose like if you start getting mad
you're going to lose so i realized oh
how do i how do i keep that in check oh
you know same thing take a breath don't
let don't get caught up in the moment
and
i got very very lucky to kind of stumble
on these things in my
in my career so that by the time i was
you know you know i was a platoon
commander and a task unit commander i
was like oh yeah take a step back look
around make sure you don't get caught up
in the problem um
interesting stuff yeah i i think this is
an opportunity for me
it would be
10 12 minutes a day and i just
get in a quiet space close my eyes and
try to follow my breath and
i can use this as an opportunity to
visualize
a race
how i want the race to go but also
some things that might go wrong during
the race and how i want to react
miss a shot sometimes the next shot is
you get another shot
you take five shots on five targets and
you only get five shots five shots if
you miss if you miss it's a penalty lap
or a one minute penalty depending on the
length of the race got it and you do
either two or four stages so that's
either a 10 shot total race or a 20
total race
and i've noticed in the past that if i
have a miss the next shot is almost like
an anger shot or a frustration instead
of so you as an example this could be an
opportunity to visualize
missing a shot that doesn't mean i'm
it's gonna
predispose me to miss that shot it just
means i can work on having the response
to a miss
in the event that that happens and the
kind of response i want to have which is
it's just the next shot it's one shot at
a time just take the next shot
but it's also a chance to
track my breathing which is you know
very critical in shooting the timing of
your breath with the trigger squeeze and
side alignment
so
what you notice is that your brain just
goes all over the place
when you're trying to focus in a calm
room you are
only doing that you don't need to eat
right now you don't need to drink you
don't need to sleep
you don't need to talk to anybody or
socialize you're just tracking your
breath
and i can't even do it
my mind's going all over the place but
guess what happens during a race
my mind's going all over the place so
the quicker that i can notice when my
mind has wandered and bring it back to
the breath this is just a simple
exercise to just notice when your mind
has wandered and bring it back to the
task at hand this in a for a tactical
leader anyone in a tactical environment
or an athletic environment i think this
is this is golden stuff
and it just takes a little bit of
discipline doing it every day
and just working on this ability to
notice your mind just notice where it's
going
it's not a problem that it's drifted
it's gonna drift it's just working on
noticing that it's drifted a little bit
quicker and then bring it back
so you work the breath you work the the
skills you're at the right altitude
you're training you're going to school
you roll into the 2018
paralympic games
and you're ready to rock and roll
i think so in retrospect i was i was
very much ready to rock and roll i i
where were those games they were in
pyeongchang south korea and i would be
going as a full-time graduate student
but what that meant was that
just lucky for me it lined up with
spring break and i was gonna skip a week
of class so i'd be gone for two weeks
total but only missed one week of class
my spring break was competing in
korea i didn't have any sense of
pressure or expectation my competitors
aren't in graduate school i don't you
know no one expects me to do anything
i'm not one of the people that the media
pre-picks to do well i didn't have good
results
i qualified whatever but i've been
training going up to vermont i was ready
to go showed up the plan was to do six
races in that about eight day span three
biathlon three cross country the first
race was the morning after the opening
ceremony didn't go to the opening
ceremony i wanted to be arrested
the first race is a sprint biathlon
which is a tough race because
you don't have time to take that cool
couple breath extra to hit the you know
you gotta because it's such a short ski
rate it's a 7.5 kilometer ski race you
got to go hard and you got to shoot fast
you guys your shots it was a windy day
and not to mention of the of all the
races to put first i think that's like
the hardest one because you're amped up
and in biathlon
i have a different optimal mental state
than i do in cross country and cross
country i am
i want to be just ready it's like psycho
right yeah like i am going to there's no
holding back bury myself on this race
and then biathlon if you have that
attitude in sochi the first race off the
bat was the sprint biathlon and like i
came in way too hot and missed three
shots i'm like way too hot but that was
a learning point and sochi i also
learned
do not look at the big screen
that has the real-time race results i'd
ski by it and look at it and see where
what don't do that don't listen to the
announcer it comes in one ear out the
other like i had learned a lot of
lessons that i was gonna
rigidly try to apply
and
just take one race at the time
don't think about the next race if a
race goes bad or if if even five minutes
ago something bad happened in this race
it's gone the only thing you can do
is affect right now i can't affect five
minutes ago
if i do things properly now the future
will be the way i want it to be but i
can't be
it does no good to think about the
future all i can do is act right here
and right now
what's right in front of me if it's a
hill i'm going to attack the hill i'm
not going to be thinking about
what's going to happen in three minutes
when i hit the shooting range so that
was kind of my mindset
this was informed by some of the classes
i had taken and just i was going to
apply this and just see how it goes you
know the first race
skied the first lap
we had good skis it was a hilly course
is a good advantage from a windy day
went through
first shot hit second hit
third shot hit four shot hit fifth shot
hit
get out go bypass the penalty loop all
right good start
ski the second lap
it's about seven minutes per lap
coming to the range all right
i'm a shooter now let's go glasses up
get to the mat lay down
take the rifle
check out the wind it was windy kind of
gusting and swirling
and first shot hit second shot hit third
shot hit four shot hit
and then i started like oh my god i
gotta hit the shot and my rhythm was off
and i'm like oh okay take a couple
breaths okay
and then
i lined up the sights and squeezed off
the round and i jerked the trigger and
it was a miss
i got i got up just matt like ah
so i skied into the penalty loop skied
it and then i exited the penalty loop
and pretty quickly there's a coach there
yelling like hey everybody everybody's
missed every like all the key players
have missed it's okay clean slate let's
go either way you go either way but but
it's nice
nice to know
everybody's like the top guys so i went
as hard as i could on that last lap and
i i remember coming into the finish line
you don't because this individual starts
it's not head to head it's like a time
trial you don't know you have a general
idea i knew that probably okay i'm in
contention right but you don't know to
the second where you are it's you just
have to find ways to push yourself
knowing that every second counts and
that last stretch going as hard as i
could i crossed the line
and i had told myself i'm not looking up
at that screen
to see the race results i'm not doing it
not doing it during the race and i'm not
doing it after and so i crossed the line
i didn't know how i finished and i just
go out and i like eating a recovery bar
and someone just taking a few minutes
later taking off the timing chip and
they said
an american won
who was it i don't know it's got a kind
of a
weird last name and my two other
teammates in the race had pretty
easy to pronounce names
maybe that was me
it it was it was seven seconds
separation between first and second
belarusian athlete got second place and
that that was unexpected gold medal gold
medal
out of the gate out of the gate good way
to start the game
and then you kept rocking through the
through the games yeah it was tough
races the next day's rate i was going
one race at a time and
the next race was a very difficult the
15 kilometer cross country race
actually
on the first lap had a great first lap
and was
right where you would want to be
on the second lap i didn't take into
account it was warm the sun was kind of
degrading the tracks i had done the
first lap on this critical fast sweeping
downhill left turn in the track which
kind of guide you around you can be in
the track or out of the track but i had
been in the track in a tuck
low aerodynamic the second lap
low
aerodynamic same thing i didn't take
into account the tracks had degraded
other skiers had gone through they had
created some exit channels so i was in
that tuck
and just
like all splayed out totally wiped out
and i got up and
i had blood on my i was racing in a
t-shirt it was so warm this is the
winter games
but none of my equipment was broken i
started skiing and i really was just
thinking
it's not about quitting or any of that
i've proven i can do it's about being a
smart athlete i got four races to go
this one is too loud it's a five lap
race 15 kilometers
35 or so more minutes does it really
make sense to
go hard and get like eighth place ninth
place i can try to work my way back into
this but
you know it's this race is gonna make me
tired i got four more to go
maybe it's actually better to sit it out
or to to you know exit the course and
just just be done it's a do not finish
did not finish of course
but
i was kind of skiing at like three
quarters effort i had lost all this
momentum that would have carried me up
and over the next hill i'm like you know
digging that digging myself out of that
hole i just don't know if it makes sense
a coach was yelling
you're still in it go go go so i just
kind of responded to the coach
like an athlete and and started going
and i'm like well let's just see what
you know it's the games i've trained
years for that let's just go see what
happens
i got 35 minutes to wait to work my way
back into it
i got time it's looking at it a
different way instead of like
does it make sense to go hard for 35
minutes it's well i got 35 minutes let's
go
so i kind of i was i was seeing my
progress improve you'd get lap splits
but again you're just pushing yourself
my lap splits after every lap we're
getting a little bit better and then on
the last lap it was
it was kind of like
five of us are kind of in it they don't
exactly know where you gotta go and so
i just i went really hard and i crossed
the line and
i ended up getting second but
for me i'm actually more proud of this
race than the gold medal race because i
think
that in sports it's it's all about
character development the sport in the
race itself the metal none of that
really matters what matters is what it
the person that it's making you and you
actually learn more from setbacks and
okay i got second place whatever place i
got that day it was about
taking a fall
despite
all my training
in the lead-up sometimes
you make mistakes or something it's just
things happen right
it's about
getting up
and and i had doubt doubt
kind of was working its way into my mind
that's probably natural
but
working through that doubt by doing what
i trained to do which is to push hard
and go hard to the finish line and so
for me
this race is more meaningful in an
internal way of course the previous
day's race i got to see the flag go up
that was very special too but
the cross country race the next day was
was more meaningful in in that sense
and you end up with uh
one gold four silvers and one bronze
yes i
i had a i just was
in that
really
sweet spot of
physical peak mental peak all lining up
in a
four-year cycle really like a seven year
cycle because i've been doing this
trying to
train since 2011 2012 moving out to
colorado so
timing that
and i was 37 years old i felt like it's
the blend this the blend of
time in the sport seven plus years plus
not being over 40 like i am now which
helps with recovery and everything that
it was just everything was lining up and
the course no doubt played into my
strengths with hill climbing and you end
up getting the uh the best male athlete
of the games is that right
that's right i
i i think that's kind of like stud
scenario right
well i you know i think you're supposed
to say this well it's not about medals
or awards of course i'm proud of it
and
that i performed like that
that i
think it was a
fair and clean field
and that
i got to represent the united states
overseas
and for me this was
just
a time that i could think you know all
this work most of it was unseen yeah you
get on a on a podi podium ceremony or
get voted the best male athlete but
nobody saw the hard work i was doing in
colorado
back in the day on those dirt roads and
i'm by myself
in the summer
and that's actually what i'm most proud
of and
what is most meaningful for me was
was that it wasn't the end result of
winning or getting second or whatever
the race result was it was putting in
the work
and
pushing myself and
growing and reconnecting with nature and
all of it but really it was about the
work and the training
so
where are we at now
so that was that was 2018. yeah 2018
unexpectedly i i did unexpectedly well
and then that opened up some
opportunities
and that i didn't
see
coming or expect but you know i had
after my injury i stayed i didn't talk
about
i didn't talk about it i had i've read
general ulysses s grant serving in the
civil war
and refusing to cash in on his service
not to write a memoir at the in the very
end of his life he did because his wife
was dying and he he was
broke broke he had been swindled and so
he decided to write a memoir i i just
i didn't feel comfortable talking about
injury i didn't even have anybody asking
me to talk about my injury so it was
pretty easy not to have to talk about it
so
when i was out there just training i was
just doing the work doing the work doing
the work and now all of a sudden it's
like oh i have these opportunities to
like
monetize or what you know just i can
actually create opportunities to give
talks and this kind of thing and that
came my way
and
i had to do some soul searching is this
is this right for me for me
in where i'm at
and what i want to do
and i thought if i
try it it's a challenge because there's
a couple things going on if i'm going to
be honest with myself one i'm
not comfortable publicly speaking
let's just be honest about it i'm not
comfortable it's like getting in the
water or trying to jump out of an
airplane it's in that realm
that really
and then the other thing is i just don't
know i mean in the teams we're getting
told you know
be a quiet professional just put in the
hard work don't seek glory this kind of
thing
so
that was all going on but okay i'll try
i'll just at least try to develop a
narrative and and see how it goes
and
i worked on that a lot and then i
started giving some talks and that came
about because i got some medals
and did had those results
those opportunities didn't exist even
though i'm the same person with
essentially the same background in 2014.
yeah jack that's just how things work in
this world yeah and i mean from my
perspective obviously uh
i look at it as not so much you taking
the opportunity to monetize what you've
been through but to me it's more
important to go out there and share what
you've been through because it can
legitimately help out a lot of people
and
um
you know i had one of our admirals one
time tell me
you know we were having a talk i had a
book coming out and you know he said
something along the lines of
you know i was like well you know this
is this is not really the quiet
professional for me to be doing this and
he said something along the lines of hey
we need to be quiet professionals but
that doesn't mean silent professionals
and there's stories that should be told
and as far as i
my opinion is you have a story that
should absolutely be told and i mean
when you're talking and we probably
could do a nine-hour podcast if we went
back and got like medical records when
you're talking about all the things that
you were going through from the time you
woke up in the hospital
like i'm a
baby like i i'm hearing the things i'm
like mad if you know oh uh you know like
the the floor's cold when i get up to go
to the bathroom in the middle of the
night i'm like oh this is weird you know
what i mean like
or like i'll i'll get like a sprained
ankle and i'll have to wear an ankle
brace and i'll be like
i'm so mad about it you know i'm sitting
here just thinking man the perspective
that you have
and and then you took it even one step
further like you're sitting there
with a guy that's a triple amputee and
he's over there getting after it trying
to make his life better so man i think
to to the contrary of what you're kind
of saying about like oh trying to
monetize this and the silent
professionals like hey man this is
things are going to help people a lot of
people that are in a tough spot
and and also
you know team guys that are going to go
through tough situations and
and and just other veterans that just
all human beings man life is hard
and and for someone like you that's been
through the hardest of situation and
still be able to get up and every day
keep getting after it man that's like
that's you i would actually tell you if
you're not sharing this story
i think that's actually kind of wrong
bro to be honest with you yeah and
that is the side of the fence i'm on
right now is that it actually could be
selfish of me to
not tell my story to just for some
valorized concept of you know
whatever not not cashing in or but
really this the opportunity presented
itself because of some success
that i didn't have four years prior but
now
there's some opportunities to talk my
friend from the teams
started this company o2x that is doing
awesome work and
there
i don't have any
holdups
of going and giving classes to
firefighters and other public service
professionals
as part of the o2x team teaching
principles of resilience or mental
toughness grit whatever you want to call
it but also working on goal setting
because i in my own life setting goals
as an athlete setting goals after my
injury setting goals at the naval
academy that all really helped me and it
doesn't mean you have to have goals but
if you have a powerful long-term goal
that can be a very a very potent force
to help you get through difficult
situations but sometimes those long-term
goals can be discouraging in the moment
of intensity and so you're teaching you
know setting
middle term as an athlete year to year i
set performance goals based on various
different categories of performance that
do not entirely include
physical training it's a lot of
nutrition sleep
mental skills and this kind of thing
tactical technical and so also teaching
them that in the moment of a tactical
situation when chaos is
just everywhere that you can set micro
goals just to be aware of that that
that this idea of you're never out of
the fight there's always something you
can do one more step forward
something that can contribute positively
that this is very powerful and also what
you taught me i teach them as well
prioritize and execute what's the most
important thing that you need to be
focusing on right now either act on it
yourself or delegate it and then what's
the next most important thing with
improvement in experience and training
you can more quickly identify what is
the most important thing to work on but
yeah just passing on those lessons
learned to
tactical athletes
as part of o2x like
that's just a no-brainer i love being
part of the team to do that yeah that's
awesome uh so are you training for 2022
now
well i competed recently in the 2022
beijing winter games and
i came back with one gold medal as part
of a team relay and
it again was a six race individual
format with the very last day being a
team event and the first race off the
bat was that same biathlon
and so now i'm going in with okay i've
had four years since 2018 i knew that
going in there would be a there would be
a little bit more attention
directed uh to whatever extent that
would be it would be more than
before 2018 which was nothing so that
there's going to be maybe some more
people wanting to do an interview or
some media outlets or some maybe
sponsorship opportunities this kind of
thing and with that
i started to feel okay
somebody sponsors you
they want you to get a medal
they want you to perform this is a
different situation so going into 2014
brand new didn't know anything going
into 2018
more experienced
but with no expectations either
externally or internally now
external expectations probably even
though no one's going to say that
but really some internal expectations
because i'm perceiving those external
expectations
that was a different different different
just each one of the games i've been to
is different in that sense but of course
training just focus on what you can do
execute the training plan working
through getting you know positive
communication with the coaches work
adjusting the training plan
cove it happened that
didn't interrupt my
personal training so much but it
interrupted the competitive scene
somewhat
and then
this season
just doing a lot of altitude exposure
training actually in bozeman montana
with the team
focusing on biathlon support at the
range we have there and showed up that
first biathlon
was
again as usual i'm just really amped up
on that one because it's the first race
and just you've been training and the
course in china was
not as advantageous for my strengths as
an athlete as it was in 2018 but it was
going to be a grind really slow snow uh
totally dehydrated so weird to watch
there's snow like those dirt on the
sides and stuff really windy place just
like blowing so they groomed the course
overnight or whenever they did it and
then you show up in the morning but the
wind was picking up
outlying snow and blowing it under the
tree and so that was just the slowest
stuff ever
so this is going to be some challenges
it's going to be grind
in that first race we were competing
against chinese athletes i hadn't seen
and seen them
in the competitive circuit and and
keeping in mind i'm a sit skier
there is
i would say a lot less technique in
cross-country sit skiing than there is
in cross country standing singing
because we're only maneuvering our poles
so there is i think an ability to
rapidly develop athletes in my sport
sitting
as compared to in the standing
discipline
but that first race i'm very proud of it
i came in hit five shots came in again
for the second and final shooting stage
hit five shots it was windy skied hard
absolutely
went as hard as i could on the last lap
because i was just off of third place
the last split i got was
on the last lap just having hit all 10
shots you're five seconds off third
place
that's
that is a motive like
motivating i okay i i just was about i
and we're at altitude so i crossed the
line and
i hadn't done a lot of racing at 5 500
feet like we were trained at it but at a
games race at that altitude when you're
going absolutely as hard as you can
it's painful
and i finished that race in fourth place
but i can tell you that that was perhaps
in my own estimation the best race i've
ever had it doesn't matter what place it
was
of course getting on the podium is nice
but it's about the execution of your own
race you do not control
who else is out there
the second race the next day was 18
kilometers again one of the better races
i felt like i've ever executed in terms
of pacing
sixth place
and then
races number three and four didn't go so
well
i sat one out was an aim to the relay
team our relay team consisted of four
legs that was the third leg and at this
point
my mentality is just take what i was
given and try to gain a couple seconds
or something pass it off to the anchor
leg and we
unexpectedly got first place we we beat
some more favorite teams and so i ended
up getting to come home with the gold
medal i can tell you that
that
was a more special experience than an
individual metal
part of the team to be part of a team
and i think i felt it no i know i felt
it during the race the difference of an
individual race
versus a race where
someone passed it off to you and you're
going to pass it off to someone else and
you don't want to let them down they're
counting on you and they're counting on
you and there's and that's a different
and so for an individual sport to have
that team element is just
awesome man right on um
i guess that brings us up to kind of
where we're at today uh
is there anything else echo you got any
questions probably a good place to wrap
it up i mean yeah
echo you got any questions yeah we were
talking um before we started recording
about jiu jitsu and you're asking pretty
kind of hardcore about the tournament
scenario how it's laid out
is that to indicate that you
are considering doing jiu jitsu
well i was asking jocko
is this possible you know is there
adaptive
adaptive martial arts yeah well actually
let me rephrase that there is no like
you would compete with other dudes and
there is no well i've never seen i've
never seen like oh he you know here's a
bunch of guys without legs that are
going to do jiu jitsu no you'll compete
against other dudes because jiu jitsu
itself is adaptive
and so
you would figure out moves that work for
you
that
you'd figure out how to do it and
there's like there's competitive
wrestlers there's wrestlers that have
fought in the ncaas that have one leg no
leg no legs
and they just adapt their body to figure
out how to win and so yeah there's
the sport itself is adaptive
but there would be no like other
special rules i mean you go to a jiu
jitsu competition there'll be people
there that are blind they do have one
rule like in wrestling the if it's a
blind dresser they have to you have to
maintain contact with them but that's
the only rule is that that's wrestling
too yeah i don't even know if that's jiu
jitsu or not yeah but um there's
we we have friends that i mean i have a
friend that's paralyzed you know uh
pretty much chest down he does jiu jitsu
that's awesome um and there's definitely
like i said there's people with one legs
i mean one of the one of the greatest
jiu-jitsu players of all time
jean-jacques machado he only has
a few fingers on one of his hands and in
jiu jitsu grips are really important we
got another friend named jeffrey al
jeffrey al has one hand and he competes
all the time and he just competes no
there's no special category other than
get some yep that's true i'm here for a
few days so maybe i could come and take
a class one one of the things i learned
and i guess the ultimate thing i've
learned as an athlete in
paralympic sport for 10 years and the
thing i was telling myself
most recently in beijing was
it's
not about
results it's not about
how you feel today it doesn't no one
cares
where you came from no one cares how old
you are
no one cares what you look like no one
cares
how much money you got how many degrees
you have none of that matters
the only thing that matters is what you
can do right here and right now
that's all that matters and ultimately
your opponent is yourself the voice
inside you that's saying
i don't know if i can do this the voice
inside you that's saying don't go that
hard it's painful
that voice that's that's actually what
you're competing against
and i think in martial arts it's
probably perhaps even more true than in
cross-country skiing yeah when we had
rob jones out we did uh we did some mat
work with him yeah see if we could give
him that little jiu jitsu bug remember
kyle maynard you knew that yeah no arms
no legs yeah straight up yep and you
train and he trained with him before he
that was a long time he might be even be
a black belt right now
yeah no arms so yeah man jiu jitsu is
for
every for everybody
uh you hey you know we're going we're
over three hours right now anything
anything else that we didn't cover
anything else you want to hit on any
final closing thoughts covered my life
thoroughly i've
very unpacked my life and uh brought up
a lot of memories so i i appreciate you
providing this platform and for asking
me to be part of your podcast it's an
honor yeah i i don't know why it's taken
so long hey if people want to find you
it's
danknasen.com right yes i do have a
website that's that's where people can
find you if they want to you you can go
speak you can go and uh help them out um
they can find you on there yeah you
don't have any social media do you no i
got on linkedin
but that's not social media
that's that's one line that i'm not
ready to cross right now yeah yeah well
right on uh you got the website though
and if people want to contact you they
can find you through there which is
awesome yeah
cool man thanks for coming on um thanks
for sharing your lesson learned for sure
uh
and and
you know
more important thanks for what you did
for the country thanks for what you did
for the teams thanks for what you've
done since representing america uh
that's awesome and and really it's just
it's always an incredible example for me
just knowing that you're out there and
no matter what's happening no matter
what you've done no matter what you've
been through i know for a fact
you're still getting up and you're
getting after it and i appreciate being
able to follow that example man thank
you thanks chaco
and with that
dan kanasan has left the building
echo charles yes sir
what was your assessment
okay so the first thing
what i didn't even realize until a few
minutes in in is when jason gardner
makes his speech one of his many about
training works and he tells the story he
was talking about this guy right yeah
100 that was him that's crazy
because to me that's one of the better
speeches especially from jason gardner
like that that's a that's a really
that's what i look forward to you know
because the way he says it and you're
talking about them so that's the muster
yeah jason talks about the effectiveness
of training and for sure enough and i
didn't want to go through all the
details and miss speak anything but some
of those details that i did cover uh for
sure
but i'll tell you what man and i kind of
talked about it but like
the amount
like waking up after being in a coma for
10 days
and then having just
the insane medical issues just insane
medical issues no legs
freaking abdomen blown apart colostomy
bag the thing going down your throat not
even allowed to drink one sip of water
you know like i complain i have a sore
like here's here's my complaint like
you know you're doing jiu jitsu and you
and you cut your mouth
sure like you cut you bite your tongue
you get ripped you get some teeth and
then you can't like eat an acidic food
for like a week it's true like i'm
complaining about this right
yeah
and and dan's over there for
for a hundred days or whatever with a
freaking tube down his throat and he's
not allowed to have one
sip of water
so
this is another one of those situations
where you just think man
you have so so nothing to complain about
there's so nothing to complain about
and dan just has a freaking awesome
attitude when he said that about when he
woke up and did you know like no time no
passage of time like that
so i got a concussion like a bad one the
kind where you have amnesia for a long
time like so basically it's like a super
super duper duper duper mild version of
that experience
so
so you've basically been through the
same thing
so i can relate so i i it was in a
football game i hit this guy and then
got knocked out but the knockout like
where my body was limp only lasted for
like
it was like a flash knockout so they
helped me up and i was all like weary
but everyone on the on my team saw me
and knew i was like out yeah out of it
so they pushed they put me to the
sideline apparently i don't remember any
of this part so but when i came to i was
just standing there in the sideline and
it was weird because just like how he
said he's
but i had amnesia too though that's that
was a weird thing i didn't remember and
i didn't even know where i was like the
kind where i'm just all standing here
you know
so but it's so cur like especially as a
little teenager right it's high school
time
it's so scary because you don't it's
like you don't know what's going on at
all and nothing is like making sense or
whatever so man i just kind of broke
down and started crying and my brother's
like my brother's on the same team
obviously he's like kind of worried and
stuff he's calling the trainer or
whatever the doctor and they're asking
me all these questions and i'm like i
don't i don't know anything and it's
weird it's really freaky
now that you're in the hospital
man
but man i was feeling them i was like
that is crazy man that's a crazy
experience
the uh the the level of discomfort
is like unimaginable right again yeah
you know for me i get a cut in my mouth
and i'm like i can't eat ketchup for a
week or whatever you know it's gonna
sting right
and he's just
you know lost his legs got the freaking
tube down his
nose
[Music]
uh having heinous real nightmares that
he thinks are real yeah
like this is crazy
so
and then for him i mean can you is there
a nicer guy out there you know just as
nice as they totally nice guy um humble
like
just freaking incredible so he did say
something and he only said it real quick
too and just continued to move on but it
was a it told a lot of the story on his
little on his mindset
when he said oh when he started uh i
think
when he started sitting up right yeah
and when then when he was considering
you know before he went into rehab he
said okay this is like my new sport
right i was like oh i see what you did
there and that's huge that's a huge deal
where you don't look at it as like oh my
gosh i'm starting from like i was at 10
and now i have to go all the way back to
one it's no it's not that it's like a
new sport it's like a new challenge that
you can start from your
almost like in a way your original
starting spot because you're new to this
sport just a new it's a new sport yeah
thing yeah and then boom you kind of
gamify it in that way where it's like oh
shoot now i can sit up okay now i can
take some steps okay i can use this and
it's like this this sport
yeah and it makes sense too because look
at him
paralympics no big deal yeah winning
that being said
you can gamify that stuff
but
at the end of the day
you can't get out of the game
and and that's why you have to have
that that like just incredible mindset
um to look at it
and you know we when we had jim swirlsey
on
and you know he had he had lost both
legs and one arm in vietnam and and that
that talk that he had with us after the
podcast when he was talking about lewis
puller jr and he said that lewis puller
jr never accepted a hundred percent what
had happened to him
and
and he's like and i did
and you you could hear dan talking about
that today you know there's you know he
said there was there were there was
times he's talking past tense like there
was times where he would be like oh why
did this happen to me oh do i really
think it was the you know he said this
happened to me because i could take it
and then he said i questioned myself did
i really do i really think that
and he was doing it in the past tense so
he
got to a point he was like okay this is
me this is my life and what am i gonna
do i'm gonna go freaking kick ass i'm
gonna become an awesome athlete i'm
gonna win a bunch of freaking olympic
medals i mean it's just
just awesome awesome example um as a
human so
anyways honored to have him on here dan
thanks for coming on brother and um
yeah if you want to help out if you want
to support if you want to support
yourself yeah
you can do it it's true by by getting
good fuel in your system yep
improving your situation whatever that
may be yeah right yeah physical is a big
one and mental by the way so we have
what discipline go energy drink i've
been drinking i've been utilizing these
all week oh yeah and it's only the
second day highly productive so far yeah
so far we got a big one you know i don't
say i don't run around saying i'm so
busy all the time
i don't say i'm not busy but i will say
this week i'm a little bit busy a little
bit busy good good so yeah i mean get a
lot of stuff done yep uh jackalful.com
get get some mulk
that's a big one yeah it's such a good
little
it's almost like a trick it is like it's
like a trick that you can have something
that tastes delicious and it's good for
you you know and it's providing you the
protein that you need to get stronger
you know the expression uh if something
seems too good to be true it probably is
yeah this one is not it's that it's not
too good
it's actually too good and true it's
good and true yeah and i said it before
i'll say it again that man it's not
especially if you're on the path you're
lifting lifting is a big one but if
you're if you're really working out and
you're trying to get that additional
protein it's hard to get the required
recommended amount of protein it's
harder than you think
so add to that one yeah easy now not if
you got that trick easy enough
uh jackalful.com you can also get the
drinks at wawa
[Music]
you can uh check out the vitamin shop
they've got everything in there too so
appreciate that go get it
also as far as supporting yourself this
podcast and america
if you're gonna get get some jeans if
you haven't already go to
originusa.com this is where you can get
your american-made genes yeah
yeah
it's real simple you know oh like oh
it's cool it's american-made and then
you oh yeah and actually you're you're
helping defeat communism yeah and
tyrannical leaders in the world yeah so
you want a new pair of jeans great get
them from orange usa.com that's that's a
positive move
if you want to help
stomp out tyrannical leadership in the
world that's enslaving a bunch of people
you can also go to originusa.com
uh you can get jiu jitsu stuff it
sounded like dan was jiu-jitsu curious
he wasn't just kind of too curious he
was really
real i was out yeah okay yeah right as i
was coming in well he made it a point
and he was he was he was uh really
interested to know how how do the
tournaments how's the tournament set up
like do you have this you have that and
you're right like right we didn't you
came in and we had to kind of record but
i didn't realize that yeah they don't
have they don't have uh like an adaptive
division yeah jiu jitsu is adaptable you
just go you adapt yeah yeah you figure
it out and by the way like what's your
weight class
because dan probably
if he had legs would probably be one 170
yeah so he's gonna be in with some
128 pounders i have no idea what his
actual weight is but he's definitely
going to be for his size and strength
upper body is going to be a force to be
reckoned with yeah and but there and
there are
do i want to say a lot or there's not a
lot but it's not a rarity to be like to
to see a guy with
one leg no legs competing in jiu jitsu
and winning so there are like very
definitive adaptive techniques that go
in and are very effective in there so
yeah
to train that jiu jitsu train that you
did for everybody that's the that's the
bottom line did you just use for
everybody where is it where did you get
that from i just said it today no but
you said it right there with a little
bit of an accent no you know why because
every body you could separate it into
two words and you have a little pun
right every body yeah and everybody back
in the day okay remember stuart cooper
cooper films so he did a video with
hobbs and mora and that that's what it
was called jiu jitsu
is for everybody and that's how he
sounded kind of like i thought it was
from that video that was good that was
my favorite song
brazilian portuguese accent comes out
you know from my
youth it's true also jacqueline store
you want to represent why you're on the
path discipline equals freedom shirts
and hats and hoodies some good stuff to
say good and also some creative designs
if you want a new one every month as a
subscription
that came out the last one uh do you
even know everybody must no no there's
one yeah they must get stoned yeah but
that's not the most controversial one
yeah what's that what's the most recent
one uh again good high level problems
oh dang check
it's good
wrote in like
what do you call like a script yeah like
a real elegant script yeah yeah yeah
with the the the logos you gotta why
does it say high level problems because
like you know you know
you know what he called the aristocrats
right that's how it looks i don't know
i'm just saying now here you want to
know the layers okay
so i
i always say we always kind of talk
about how like people now or it's been
said that people now they're complaining
about like dumb stuff right everyone's
offended or all this first world
problems first world problems the idea
that's like the thing is sure it can be
viewed as bad especially when you
compare it to real problems quote
unquote real problems but it's only
natural to have these problems and if
they're problems
they still need to be solved most of
them can be solved with attitude of
course
rather than you know killing a bunch of
first world problems good it's
essentially no no it means first world
problems need to be solved just like any
other problem
no matter how easy or hard but they
still exist
but you still have to have the same
attitude you gotta have that the good
attitude the same good attitude exactly
it's just a higher level good
quote-unquote higher level yes all right
so there you go shirt locker get some of
that uh subscribe to the podcast
jocko underground.com we've been
rolling out some jocko underground
pretty interesting
topics coming out there talking about
various
things on earth and answering a lot of
questions jacquelineground.com if you
want to help us with our own little
platform that we've got going just in
case we get banned
just in case we get
censored yeah what else band sensor gm
band is censored uh cancelled whatever
you know i mean i
i don't think
well then again i don't know nowadays
cause remember youtube you could say
pretty much whatever
as far as like actual words like you
know how they're swearing on youtube
right that was never a thing
and then there's certain like words
that they like
make it a point to like bleep out so
their channel doesn't get cancelled like
there's people i listen to and they like
cut out the words i've heard that but
the words that you're talking about are
words like
covid have you ever heard
a podcast like that where they're saying
the word covet and they edit it out yeah
yeah or hat or like half the word it's
weird so that just makes me kind of
weird not doesn't make me nervous but it
makes me think like wait a second why
are they doing that because they might
have got canceled or demonetized or what
is that like why we have jocko
underground.com exactly because
we can't control these other platforms
but we we meeting all of us we all
control
underground.com so if you want to
support that check it out check out
youtube by the way hopefully we you can
watch this episode even though i just
said kovid with no frame of reference
whatsoever i just said the word twice no
three times i think
so hopefully you can see us on there uh
subscribe to it check out the origin usa
channel as well
if you want to know what's happening
there
uh psychological warfare don't forget
about dakota meyer making cool stuff to
hang on your wall it's
flipsidecanvas.com i've written a bunch
of books check them out we got echelon
front leadership consulting
inside of echelon front we have the
extreme ownership academy
and this is
guidance on life
guidance on life how to interact with
other human beings which is what you're
doing
that's what we all do we have to do it
whether it's just the person that you
live with mom dad brother sister husband
wife whether it's your
landlady across the hallway you got to
build a relationship with her so you
don't get evicted
so if you want to help
learn to build relationships help have a
better life go to extreme ownership
for the academy
if you want to help service members
active and retired their families
check out mark lee's mom mama lee she's
got a charity organization
it's america's mightywarriors.org
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved and don't forget about heroes
and horses.com
micah think getting people out into the
wilderness
for sure echo and i we're both on
twitter
we're on the gram we're on the facebook
but listen come fair warning
better watch out for that
algorithm because it's looking to grab
you right by the throat and pull you
back in actually doesn't grab you by the
throat it grabs you by like
by like a gentle kind of like handhold
and it kind of lures you in there it's
not aggressive by the uh uh what's the
amygdala
yeah i don't know it grabs you by the by
the gray matter by the gray matter just
eases you into the algorithm next thing
you know you look up and you just wasted
17 minutes of your life looking at a
bunch of stupid things so watch out for
that uh thanks once again to dan
connauson for coming on and thanks dan
for everything you've done
everything you've done for america for
the teams and the way you represent
america
in the olympics awesome
and
like i said it's it's awesome for for me
to think that no matter what
no matter what's going on in your world
you're out there getting after it that
is an example for all of us to follow
and thanks to all the service men and
women who have paid the price of freedom
in blood
we are only here
because of your sacrifice
and we thank you for it and thanks to
all the work done by our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol secret service and all first
responders out there
you also sacrifice so that we can be
safe and we are grateful for what you do
and to everyone else out there whatever
whatever excuse you have whatever
justification you make up in your head
whatever rationalization you allow to go
on in your mind just stop it
just stop it
the excuses and the justifications and
the rationalizations are not
valid and we know that
we know that because of guys like dan
kanasana who
face incredible challenges
but he doesn't make excuses he takes
action
he overcomes he drives on so let's all
of us
be more
like damn
and go out there every day
and get after it
and until next time this is echo and
jocko